look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's gonna
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
old motor because pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children
the evil's growing it's coming what you
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
[Music]
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pagman
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe rogan if you're
just joining us rudy giuliani is
sweating his face off explaining to us
why trump really won the election again
inspectors
every state
almost every prove this
was thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out
properly wait he's saying there was a
dead person in the envelope
rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow i mean is
this a normal amount i don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here i'll be in the
lawsuit that comes out duty's melting
arizona is a k is a state that we're
looking at very very carefully strongly
looking at it i would say we're probably
i assume
she's working if she's working for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time
you should have had the time in and that
you to go look for that
[Music]
that's your job
like it's my job to defend the president
oh representative president it's lane
michigan wisconsin
is he bleeding did you see is he
bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that folks needed to
overcome outside to find out
does that hair die is to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood
but in the material oh my god it's
everywhere's ten
thousand at least
and we're getting he's gotta get off the
stage and there are other aspects of
this fraud on the morning of november
someone's gotta get him a napkin they
were gonna count the these this new kind
of balance
i've never seen anything like this
what on earth it's getting onto his
shirt now she can and in wisconsin any
jury would accept as they heard this
evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup should the city describe
that to you oh my god it's all over his
face
he's gonna need a towel dealing with
evidence i don't know guys it's sounding
like trump won isn't it based on this
[Music]
trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes
eight
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
well welcome everybody we are moments
away from a donald trump
rally
during which he is at least in theory
supporting other candidates although in
practice it's all about himself and you
will soon see that mark my words
this is a rally again it's all
theoretical
at least in theory in favor of two very
important in terms of the balance of
power republican nominees on the
gubernatorial side
doug mastriano who will literally steal
the election in 2024 if given the
opportunity a dangerous
almost certainly anti-semite racist
um
wearing confederate uniforms
employing as an advisor an overt
anti-semite who says republicans should
not even welcome jews into the movement
i mean it bonkers like
crazy crazy crazy stuff
that's on the one hand
and then on the senate side
supporting quack television dr
mehmet oz
who
is laughably incompetent and unqualified
and john fetterman should crush him like
a bug but we will see if that happens
and we're going to be looking at some
polling very very soon we are monitoring
streams from news max as well as right
side broadcasting
right side broadcasting apparently just
airing
surveillance footage i guess is this
from the is this from mar-a-lago is that
what this is about oh it looks like it
is
it looks like this is the fbi showing up
to mar-a-lago very very interesting
stuff
i think that this is what this is who
the hell knows
and then uh these these are the these
are the channels okay oh this is from oh
this is marjorie taylor green oh this is
the swatting this is when marjorie
taylor green was swatted okay
sorry i it's so hard to keep up with
what this is but it's it's nonsense
obviously
uh okay let's look at some polling here
let's look at some polling here
um in terms of masteriano versus shapiro
now this is a choice between
on the republican side a disgusting
republican candidate
who believes trump won in 2020 and if
given the chance would steal
pennsylvania
if if he can uh for the republican
candidate in 2024 even if the republican
candidate loses that's what's that's
what the republicans are running
on the democratic side it's a completely
unremarkable
benign milktoast democrat named josh
shapiro
those are the choices now
the latest data
is that on average
shapiro is up six
and if you look at the last three polls
which are the only ones from august in a
trafalgar group that's a right-leaning
poll shapiro is plus four over
masteriano in a franklin and marshall
poll shapiro is plus 11 and in an
emerson poll shapiro is plus three so
given that masteriano is an over
authoritarian lunatic
it's very sad that shapiro is only up
six this doesn't mean anything other
than everybody must vote okay that's one
of the races that
trump is supporting doug mastriano
tonight
the other important race in pennsylvania
is oz
oz versus fetterman
fetterman um brilliant guy
um you know just to kind of
not
doesn't have these elite vibes just
seems like a normal guy educated
certainly highly educated the current
lieutenant governor running for senate
and then you have tv doctor mehmet oz
who
you know takes every position on every
issue to try to please somebody i mean
really a horrible horrible person here
on average fetterman is plus 6.5 and
again when we look at the four poles
from august in a susquehanna pole it's
fetterman plus five emerson is fetterman
plus four franklin and marshall
fetterman plus 13 and in a right-leaning
trafalgar group poll fetterman plus four
so the good news is fetterman's winning
the bad news is
mehmet oz couldn't possibly be a worse
candidate i guess if he was accused of
serial rape or something he could be
worse right i mean it's
hard to imagine he could be a worse
candidate and yet fetterman's only up by
six and a half
so both of the of these guys
really really really need to lose and we
are going to see donald trump come out
in mere moments and presumably tell you
why you should vote for mastriano and oz
my guess is essentially the opposite of
everything trump says will be true but
i'm withholding judgment on that i want
to first wait and see what is actually
said now if we zoom out from
pennsylvania just a little bit and we
will ban
men no no no i just mean let's look at
the numbers more broadly everybody take
it easy
if we look at the joe biden approval
we have dark brandon rising as you can
see after bottoming out at 37.5
approval in mid-july
we now have seen a dramatic spike in
biden's approval
up to 42.7 percent now i know that it's
sort of like a low number
but in this historical
sort of moment in which we are
uh it's actually not bad and it's it's a
significant increase and the the hope
would be
that this spike for joseph r biden jr
buoys
democrats in the fall so that lunatic
republicans don't take over now if we
want to go down and just compare
biden's current approval to past
presidents
two a month and a half ago
you had to go back to truman in the
1940s to find a president as unpopular
as biden at that point in his presidency
however we now see that biden has
basically tied trump for approval at
this point in his presidency so biden
trump even at this point this is um
591 days in i i guess
um closing in on barack obama
closing in on where bill clinton was
has surpassed where ronald reagan was in
approval at this point in his presidency
roughly equal with jimmy carter
and um
yeah ahead of where truman was so all of
a sudden
starting to look like a much more
typical presidency now in terms of the
senate
democrats are favored to win in the
senate by a greater than two to one
margin democrats currently control the
senate and by a 68 to 32 percent chance
democrats are expected to hold the
senate things not looking quite so good
in the house in the house republicans
are favored to win by a roughly three to
one margin now important to mention that
these numbers have improved for
democrats significantly over the last
six weeks potentially not reflected in
these numbers is the recent momentum on
the democratic side if you look at what
happened to pathetic sarah palin in the
special election in alaska if you look
at what happened in new york if you look
at what happened in michigan there is a
sort of qualitative momentum behind
democrats that i don't believe is yet
reflected in these numbers now i'm not
saying democrats are going to keep the
house i am not saying that
but i think democrats are going to be
in the fight i think democrats are going
to be in the fight let's put it let's
put it that way okay
things getting completely out of control
at the trump rally as usual we are
monitoring newsmax as well as right side
broadcasting let's listen to just a few
seconds of this nowadays or it was
generational for them but the majority
of pennsylvania is known for their blue
collar industry the mining the coal
industry and the biden industry as
dividend administration put it has put a
huge hole to that so if we can get rid
of the bite administration we can open
that back up these people are going to
live whole new lives yeah yeah a
completely meaningless pablum um being
presented as political analysis on right
side broadcasting i don't think it'll
surprise
any of you any of you that's for sure um
okay
let's see david do you shop at trader
joe's uh sometimes
sometimes yeah sometimes i will shop at
trader joe's sure
why not right um
kind of an odd question but that's fine
i'll welcome it let me say thank you to
a few people thank you to cindersoul
jada love
colors atk you do suck
jen here
all uh getting subscriptions on twitch
today putting us at five kicking us off
also want to say thank you
to the great jennifer regains who just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
and his new member number six and also
thank you to sean fertel
and jason sickmeyer each gifting a
membership on my website putting us at
eight super chat's coming in
super space sloth says can you imagine
waking up from a 30-year coma and seeing
a trump rally on television
i'd want to go back in the coma well
said
well said an ugly ugly ugly situation
that is for damn sure
um oh couple different things
maybe some of you can help me with this
no i'm
no no i'm not about to ask you for 11
000 votes i need 11 000 votes give me a
break here's what i'm going to mention i
have this idea
that i want to start a dubbed david
pakman show in spanish this would be a
separate youtube channel david pakman
show en espanol beautiful thing
with dubbed content yes i speak spanish
but i just don't have the time in my day
to redo all the content in spanish we've
looked at services like dub partner
which i believe does dubbing for mr
beast
they have like a 48-hour turnaround and
it would literally cost us 10 grand a
month for them to dub all of our content
doesn't work for a show like ours so
what i'm asking you is if anybody knows
we may have to just like hire someone
who does both the youtube part and the
dubbing to basically
dub and manage the spanish youtube
channel or something okay
we're open to ideas is the point but
we're kind of out of ideas
so if anybody
has some ideas
for how we might be able to do this you
know we need relatively quick turnaround
i mean it's a big project it's a big
project there's no doubt about it i just
think 10 grand a month is a little much
for something that will initially make
zero
zero
so open to ideas you know we looked on
websites like fiverr and upwork to see
about over people but most of them are
like you know we charge 150 bucks for
one line like for a for an ad
we have an hour a day of content so i
don't know but i'm i'm if anybody has
any ideas i would be interested in you
know you can email info at
davidpakman.com that's number one the
other thing is i am now ready people
have been asking david
with tears in their eyes people ask me
david
what is happening with the finance
channel we are launching a personal
finance channel in english okay
i am now ready to welcome subscribers
the channel is launching imminently
there is an incredible situation we
right now
have
one subscriber
on pacman finance that's youtube.com
pacmanfinance
that one subscriber is me
so for people interested in the finance
channel
youtube.com
slash
pacman finance
and because we only have one subscriber
we're not even on social you need five
subscribers to get on socialblade can
you imagine
so if you want to get in early
let's see if anybody did we now have 10
subscribers on the finance channel this
will be launching very very soon i think
it's going to be great
and it'll be completely different
content just for people who like uh
personal finance stuff i'll be going
over my asset allocation we'll be
talking about all sorts of different
things i will not be giving any stock
tips it's just not what it's going to be
okay so hopefully soon we'll be on
social blade
um
yeah probably takes a little while but
any case youtube.com
pacman finance we've gotten 128
subscribers fantastic okay we're loving
that that's going to launch very soon
and i'll have more information for
people
about it
and yeah there's going to be elements of
i guess i guess elements of money oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad well that's not a
claim i've ever made alex okay thank you
very much super chat's coming in sean
says thank you for pronouncing my name
correctly i hereby reject my request for
a special master good news
travis says thank you just signed up on
your website please give a shout out to
my new kitten lemmy lemmy welcome
welcome welcome even though i'm not a
cat guy
we welcome cats in the audience i have
no problem with cats in the audience
it's fine
david sir a little birdie told me you
got a voicemail from herschel walker i
think my impression was spot on
congrats on little pacman all right we
will get to that i'm sure
dungus magrungas says being smart with
my money and paying you ten dollars to
say i am now subscriber number 11 on the
finance channel congrats dungus that's
super exciting stuff super exciting
stuff let's take a look at a little bit
of the flavor
of what's going on at the trump rally i
think many of you will find this stuff
extremely disturbing extremely
disturbing let's take a look at some of
this stuff
let's see what we have here
mega republicans chanting trump one
trump one this is a cult this is a cult
i'm sure biden's just shaking in his
booties because there's completely
unhinged clowns saying that the guy who
lost by 8 million actually won oh i'm
sure biden's really really scared really
really scared of that
um let's see what else we've got
marjorie taylor green at the rally
saying trump won
and you want to know something else
pennsylvania president trump won the
2020 election
that's right we know president imagine
standing for that these people are
really really sick
really really sick sick people
sick people
um let's see what else we have trump won
save america from the rally
let's see what else
mastriana who even cares what masteriano
says the guy's such a clown i mean these
people are really okay let's see this
guy wants trump back because he reminds
him of his abusive parents what
what they say about donald trump they
say that he's mean and everything well
you know what when you're growing up it
was your father who kicked you your
mother kicked you in the ass to keep you
on a straightened hour and that's what
he did the straight and hour jesus
i went on the leader i don't want a lamb
that's right a leader a leader not a
lamb we know biden isn't leading much
i mean literally full employment under
biden two jobs reports in a row that are
just blowing out expectations these
people are
sick sick people but you know what
you've got to fight him at the ballot
box because as sick as they are each of
their votes counts as just as much as
each of our votes
that's the reality
okay we still have time fine
let's see what else we have from this
event a lot of empty seats during
marjorie taylor green's portion not a
big not a big surprise
let's see what else we have here from
the rally
this is the same margaery cleep clip
we've seen
here's a guy with a trump flag running
around
green is going out of her way not to
mention oz oh interesting
this november it's freedom versus
tyranny on the ballot
and i'm expecting you people to show up
at the polls you can't send a man to the
senate named fetterman that loves bernie
sanders communist policies
oh no
he will destroy this country
you have to elect a governor doug
mastriano to protect pennsylvania well
so she says don't vote fetterman
wow that's weird huh
no mention of oz though yeah
i know you're gonna do it
you've got to go all the way down the
ballot and check the republican box all
the way all of the republicans
not mentioning anybody's names
but just if it says republican vote for
them
marjorie taylor greene says fauci thinks
he's going to retire but he's going to
go to jail let me tell you something
else
this nation suffered under democrat
coven lockdowns but it's dr anthony
fauci he thinks he's going to retire let
me tell you something i think that man
belongs in jail
oh but that's not enough
that's let me tell you yeah the standing
ovation lines
are are the the most culty it it's just
unbelievable these people are truly
unbelievable
truly unbelievable
thanks to naria
matt gates on white bronco and dave
schmidt for the twitch subscriptions
putting us at 11. i also want to say
thanks to virginia johnson sears as well
as travis hyde
for signing up on my website
joinpacman.com
and a big big thank you
to frankfurfers
for gifting a subscription on my website
joinpakman.com number 14.
nettles says david sir since the mag
cult will dominate the republican
primary in 24 how in the world can trump
lose the nomination it's a foregone
conclusion to me it's not yet clear to
me i am reserving judgment on that
i uh wha what do people in the chat
think is it a foregone conclusion that
trump gets the 24 nomination or not i
believe it's not i think depending on
how november goes and depending on
whether trump's indicted etc
i think that it's conceivable desantis
could defeat trump
defeat trump let me know in the chat yes
or no foregone conclusion
my belief is no
not a foregone conclusion
taking a very informal survey of the
chat it seems
a majority agrees with me on this
now that doesn't mean trump wouldn't win
it
i just don't think it's a foregone
conclusion
let's look at a few other clips here
from the rally
now to learn of the many ways you can
help support our efforts
and i would like to personally thank
president trump
for taking the time to listen
and for allowing me the opportunity to
share this message with all of you hmm i
guess that's like a j6 mom or something
like that it's kind of weird
uh okay
let's see what else we have from the
rally right side broadcasting
interviewed interviewed marjorie trader
green there's a school in texas that
someone identified you ready for this
for a cat
and they made them put out a litter box
i thought it was something from the
onion
absolutely true wow that is because our
principles don't stand up anymore right
you know back my parents were in
education so if i that would have been
brought up they would have been slapped
the hell out of that classroom
anti-traditionalism that's happening
right now is
on every level it seems like no they're
embracing lies i mean literally what's
funny to me is also like
so let me let me see if i can put this
into words
on the one hand
part of the reason that the right does
so well
is they are reactionary and radical and
hyperbolic right they they're outraged
at everything everything is fear porn
everything is almost the end of the
world etc etc
but in reality their ideas are so boring
it's just like everything different is
bad progress is bad new technology is
bad green energy is bad it's it's all
it's all just bad
the exciting ideas are actually on the
left but this this also this is as much
a criticism of the right as it is of the
left
the left also has not done the job that
that we should
uh to show that like actually the the
the stuff to get viscerally excited
about is on the left and it's positive
stuff
positive stuff not negative stuff like
the right does but because this is so
boring
oh it's again they're against
traditionalism who cares embracing lies
okay if some student wants to pretend
like a cat and use a litter box after
school
that's their prerogative whatever by the
way
i can only imagine the little litter box
story is at least being distorted i've
never heard it before i can i but i i
have to assume they're not really
telling the truth of the story but no
the school and school resources and the
other students and teachers should not
have to be uh put through that because
it's a lie and yeah
yeah well
very very exciting stuff
here's
a a sign from a man dressed like a
satmar hasidic jew although i don't know
we are god-fearing people trump won 2020
we shall not sit idly by while truth and
justice are under attack by the election
fraud deniers so
listen
i don't speak for the jewish people but
this guy doesn't either and jewish
americans are of the most uh left-wing
voting blocs in the country i believe
actually the most
maybe behind black folks or right up
there
so
vile vile sign
um bikers for trump have arrived at the
rally uh very exciting i'm sure many of
many of you were
eagerly awaiting that the let's go
brandon shirts are there
guy at the trump rally says he was in dc
on january 6th and was investigated but
not charged we were going to come back
the first saturday of every month and
give they gave us not my present for
four years we were gonna say not my
president and have these speeches every
month like clockwork what an
embarrassment that would be so the
democrats had to pull the security and
let a riot happen and let somebody get
die
so they could stop these rallies so they
could say see trump rallies are
dangerous people get killed yeah who
gets killed we get killed
yeah that's the goal to stop these dumb
rallies uh but also on top of that
because the fbi when they came to my
house they wanted to know if i was
plotting on overthrowing the government
wow now what am i supposed to answer
that oh yeah i am actually yeah
but
oh boy this guy's dangerous very very
dangerous desiree says ring of fire had
a video of marjorie taylor green trying
out for season one of american idol does
anyone think it was really her i can't
tell yeah what do people in the chat
think if you've seen the video
is that marjorie taylor farren had that
video is it marjorie taylor green trying
out on american idol people are saying
it wasn't her it was her
it wasn't her
okay
48 voted for trump in 2020 default to
popular vote or recognized biden
alienated nearly half the country with
his red fascist speech dark brandon is
dark oh give me a break
give me a break
um
yeah that's that's just that's bonkers
bonkers bonker stuff
let's see what else we have from the
rally
we might not have that much more
necessary we might not necessarily have
that much more
what's this about all right coming over
here
mark we got we got my white supremacist
friend back here my boy mark from
germany i'm around here with all these
racist white people
i'm here to stand with president trump
we gotta get adolf joe out of office
baby
did he say adolf trump
we gotta get adolf trump out of office
what was that i'm here to stand with
president trump we gotta get adolf joe
out of office oh adolph joe adolph joe
look at the look at the expression on
this guy's face
man i don't know guys the left should be
scared because the right's getting
better at comedy
guy at trump rally can you do me a favor
smack nancy pelosi
no violence
marjorie says the new york times is the
worst spreader of j6 conspiracy theories
think about the rush let me turn that
down a little action collusion hoax lies
they spread on that network nonstop new
york's time
non-stop conspiracy theorists they are
the biggest especially on january 6th
biggest conspiracy theorists they say
president trump organized it they say
marjorie taylor green organized it they
blame jim jordan they blame scott perry
they blame matt gates they blame all of
us we had nothing to do with it and then
woman at trump rally thanks steve bannon
for providing news to her
oh this i have to say
i'm uh juliana lembred i'm from moss
beach new jersey and steve i just want
to thank you for everything that you do
we're so thankful for uh
just american news real american
literally praising a criminal news you
know
uh real journalism and uh we're just so
excited to be here yep wow
steve bannon has fans that's that's
shockingly hard to believe but
apparently true
apparently true oh here's marjorie
continuing her attack on electric
vehicles want to destroy everything you
see right here you know i tell you
something right now i don't know one
single electric vehicle battery that
sounds like that
[Laughter]
you know on in my segment about electric
vehicles from last week
i gave all this list of reasons
why republicans should like electric
vehicles but they don't and one of the
things i said they don't like is the
electric vehicles don't do big boy vroom
vroom
and i was sort of joking but that's what
that's exactly what marjorie taylor
green is saying right here they don't go
vroom vroom
wow these people are a joke
really a joke i mean it is shocking how
much of a joke these people are
wow
wow
channel zero says people constantly
confuse democratic socialism with actual
socialism and communism maybe it needs a
new name yeah that's for the socialists
to figure out i'm a social democrat
myself which is a form of capitalism so
i'll let the folks in that movement
um
decide what to name it david have you
heard of truth yeller it's a right-wing
comedy special on daily wire i got as an
ad before your stream it's giga cringe
i'll look at that later
sir i emailed you about military
recruitment in high schools and was
curious about what your opinion is i'm
against it
what are the implications of the
republicans winning the house is
mccarthy becoming the speaker of the
house i'm really concerned well if
republicans win the house and democrats
keep the senate it'll be
total obstruction for two years at the
end of which republicans will say look
democrats got nothing done for the last
two years thanks to us you should vote
for a republican in 2024 for president
that's their plan
that's their plan it's very very it's
very overt and straightforward
that's uh
and it's sad
and it's sad
um all right listen i i i do want to ask
you for one small favor i need 11 000
votes give me a break nothing like that
nothing like that the favor is as
follows
we are a community supported program the
streams
the new finance channel which i would
love for you to sign up for it's it's
free uh we now have our first uh almost
500 subscribers on the finance channel
the podcast all these different things
these things are basically funded by you
okay we have a membership program on our
website it's join pacman.com is where
you go
it's really easy to sign up we do an
extra show every day for our members
alex jones
hates our bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad that's not
alex jones hates the bonus show i can
think of no better endorsement of the
bonus show than that um and we have a
coupon code today the code is indict
ind ict
we all know what indict means we know
why that's the code right now we're all
following what's going on with the trump
crime family okay the code is indict you
sign up your name pops up on my screen
you become an american hero or a hero of
whatever nation you live in
and then this blue bar fills up and
hopefully we get to a hundred and
everybody wins okay so some people who
just did this and i'm gonna thank them
francisco castrejon
beautiful name
is a new member
katie mccartney is a new member carol
bookie is a new member so that's three
14 plus three is 17 and we inch closer
you can also gift memberships on the
website although i recommend getting one
for yourself first
xavier franco or xavier franco just
gifted a membership that puts us at
18. jason sickmayer just gifted one okay
that puts us at 19. and it's a very
modest goal
we've had streams where we get to a
thousand
the goal today is only a hundred i also
want to thank people signing up on
twitch including dave schmidt ein kakadu
wookie jack not tenuous that's four
that puts us at 23. so you have options
tonight mike pillow is advertising his
coupon codes on right side broadcasting
and on uh newsmax and then i have a
coupon code indict it's your choice you
can go with the pillow code or not and
yes do not adjust your tv screens
s prez has gifted over a thousand
subscriptions on twitch that is
absolutely correct and is the top gifter
of all time followed closely by skittle
stew with 605.
these are shocking numbers
these are numbers no one has ever seen
before to be perfectly frank
as we stand by
let me listen to a couple of voicemails
that have come in
okay
just a couple of voicemails
to see
what is on people's minds because there
are things
i guess on people's minds
hey david it's tommy if marjorie green
taylor green trader green
is saying that trump won why is she
trying to always file articles of
impeachment against
non-president joe biden oh yeah no she
would just say trump is the rightful
winner but joe biden has been made
president
they have a talking point to get around
that one
johnny says couldn't the supreme court
just rule a president has the right to
declassify documents i don't know that
that's subject to the supreme court i'm
not sure about that
david we've seen stories stating truth
central is floundering why isn't it
being propped up by rich right wing
benefactors i don't think they i don't
think those people care about it
mischievous and deceitful chicanerous
and deplorable
it's a pretty good summary of some of
the people we're seeing here tonight
that's for damn sure
if you're just joining us donald trump
is expected any moment look at the
excitement in this room look at the
excitement there are men coughing
there's a guy looking at a little kid
there's a woman dancing these people are
ready for 90 uninterrupted minutes of
donald trump it is absolutely
electric in this room electric in this
room the crowd is on fire
and uh i expect trump will be somewhere
between two and three hours late tonight
now i hope he's only going to be a few
minutes late because i have some
beautiful pha for dinner tonight one of
my favorite soups
truly one of my favorite soups
and uh if trump is too late i might have
to have it on stream
i'll do it
don't dare me
don't dare me because i will do it
i will do it thank you to flumride the
master debater
and mackel as well as eso tv for the
twitch prime subscriptions
huge numbers of memberships are dumping
in on my website i want to say thanks to
jamin walker and daniel stewart
as well as soren hill
thanks to you guys i also want to say
thanks to people gifting subscriptions
including conal bredenberg
jason sickmeyer
gifting two
actually gifting three
that's a total of eight
putting us at 35. couple other super
chats coming in
preston ring rose says i'm ready for
cheeto nero i know yes we are
we are all
sort of horrified but awaiting
the arrival of trump
uh let's see if there are any
new
videos from the rally
a lot of very dystopian stuff
okay the the story about the litter box
seems to have already been debunked
let's see what the explanation is for
the litter box story
um
okay it is of course not true the claim
that students who identify as furries
are now requesting litter boxes instead
of restrooms is anti-trans rhetoric that
has been debunked time and time again in
many states okay so it's just not true
i don't think it's a shock to you
but what marjorie taylor green said
isn't true
big shocker huh
big big shocker
all right let's take a little bit of a
listen to the right side broadcasting
coverage and see what could they
possibly even be talking about for him
he can say what he wants on there which
is the
that's the first amendment freedom of
speech come on are they promoting truth
essential
yeah it's amazing but we're glad that uh
you're joining us here today and uh you
know we just encourage everybody to
share this broadcast let everybody know
exactly how you feel about watching this
rally tonight and we in the moderators
that have been interacting i want to say
a special thought shout out to our
moderators that were working on
youtube we got some of the best crew
back at the station they really go on
there and make sure that the chats don't
get out of line as far as obscene or
anything like that i think there was
literally pro hitler stuff on their
youtube chat later shout out to
everybody back in the studio right now
and back at the corporate office that
are sitting behind these computer
screens rolling the graphics you're
seeing on screen rolling the commercials
that you're seeing rolling all over
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines well that could be
a problem for their moderation team
that's for sure
a mussolini trump attacked the doj today
on truth central scary i believe you i'm
not even going to pull it up right now
but i believe you
ben says dave good to see you live as
always correct me if i'm wrong but is
this dump's first rally after the fbi
search everyone go subscribe to pacman
finance yeah uh this is trump's first
rally since the search warrant
and i can only
assume
that trump is going to be
extraordinarily unhinged like out of
control unhinged
but it remains to be seen all we can do
is wait and see
and that is part of uh
that's part of being patient my friends
bail and aw boyne thank you for the
twitch prime subscriptions
we are only 55 twitch subscribers from
breaching 2000 once again which would be
a beautiful number i can't tell you
how many people here are signing up for
memberships on my website dumps big
massive dumps they're dumping in i want
to say thanks to tom toft
belinda hunt
ernest shaffer
chad mello
um matt hindmarch
brett steves
joe mantica
as well as
norma mouldin
that's eight people there folks i really
appreciate that eight plus 37 okay eight
plus seven is fifteen five carry the one
that puts us at 45
is that right
i believe so also thanks to sheila owen
for gifting a subscription let me tell
you something if you want a free
membership truly free like no strings
attached okay
go to davidpakman.com free membership
and fill out the form we go in order
you get it's totally free but
please for everything that is holy do
not email me about the free memberships
if you email me about a free membership
the email gets flushed if you want the
free membership you go to
davidpakman.com
free membership and you fill out the
form emailing me won't help i get emails
from people who go yeah i was wondering
about the free membership because i'm on
this or that i lost it
everybody has a story
but we just have a process and it's
davidpakman.com
free membership okay
very very important very very very
important
um
okay
what else did i have here oh sorry we
were in the middle of voicemails when we
got distracted
uh
trump is still saying that if he get if
he becomes president he's gonna
pardon all these insurrectionists
first of all i don't believe the doj is
gonna allow him to run after stealing
those documents and second even if he
does manage to get president there's no
way in hell he's gonna
pardon the insurrectionists because
he only cares about himself yeah i agree
trump's not pardoning the
insurrectionists
all the other stuff the doj won't let
trump run that's not exactly how the law
works
but i agree i think the the pardons
trump is dangling are just to get people
to be ready to riot if he's indicted i
don't think he actually has any plan any
plan to pardon the insurrectionists i
think you are completely and totally
correct
let's see what else is on people's minds
uh david peckman what we saw with joe
biden's speech is a man suffering from
trump to range syndrome
joe biden i think is finally losing it
uh his marbles he's
totally
gone unhinged and became a
full-fledged lunatic um
with his latest speech with the visual
objects and uh
all right well i don't really care what
troy york says i'm actually
extraordinarily bored by troy york's
opinions lately
um
i don't know
oh he called back
um
hey i just want to let you know that dan
bonchino's name is uh
bon
you can pronounce it um
you're very articulate when you speak
and for you to mispronounce his name
yeah that's how i'm pronouncing it
danbongino what do you mean
what's troy york all worked up about
i think i'm saying it correctly
um
wudix says i don't agree that it was
wrong for the fbi to inform facebook
about incoming russian misinformation
seems logical to me am i missing
something not in particular no you're
not missing anything in particular
um
i don't know that i have too many other
voicemails i want to play i know people
were hoping for something from whitney
let me see if i have anything
yeah you greasy venezuelan oh biden is a
uniter oh yeah sure he is he's a lion
son of a [ __ ] and what do you do stick
your head up his ass
tell the truth for a change you and your
figures you know everything
yeah [ __ ] you know nothing
i think we should uh lock and load you
as well as the rest of your creeps
very interesting uh okay let's see what
else we've got
um but i really think that modern-day
feminism really puts like ahead on
what's like
for the general male population and you
know what's for a man individually
and what's for like the health of our
nation
so i feel like it really emphasizes that
doing things in general for like general
male population all right well that's
pretty interesting actually from uh from
whitney uh b dog also called in
hey what up dog this is bdog you know me
dog
this message is for pack dog i'm
wondering what your thoughts are on
if
in the alaska special election
if sarah palin was the only republican
on the ballot do you think she would
have defeated the democrats i'll take my
answer off the air pack dog yeah i mean
mathematically it's possible
mathematically it's possible but um
listen what i care about is reality
sarah palin lost with the system that
alaska had much like trump won in 2016
because of the electoral college not
because of the popular vote that's the
system we have so the speculations about
if the systems were different
are not particularly interesting to me
people asking when does the speech start
16 minutes ago
supposed to start 16 minutes ago
i want to say thank you to michelle
langston and keisha mcgill
for signing up at
joinpackman.com folks it is an
incredible day
this is trump's first rally since the
fbi search warrant we have a coupon code
indict
we depend on your support
and i would love for you to sign up on
my website joinpakman.com we have a
modest goal of a hundred new members
we're at 48.
now 48 when the goal is 100 on a
percentage basis is
4 divided by 0.4
i think that's 52 right if we have 48
out of 100 members
we're 52 of the way to the goal is that
is that right
does anybody know
by the way
i'm kidding i actually get emails when i
do that and people go david you
miscalculated 48 out of 100. it's not 52
it's 48
oh
thank you
thank you i didn't know that
i didn't know that i'm glad you were
able to tell me that
what would happen if trump was indicted
at the rally i mean that would probably
be the most viral moment in amer in the
history of american politics
lock and load is a threat right that's
scary stuff love from canada stays safe
yeah the fbi knows about that guy
already
imagine if the feds showed up and
arrested trump in the middle of his
speech that would be incredible yeah
that same idea seems to be on a lot of
people's minds
on a lot of people's minds
i want to say thanks to big bird janet
one pirate
sling blade dre is beast
laker
chunky strudel for signing up on twitch
putting us at 54. powerful twitch
subscriptions
dave i guess i'm behind on the dp news
you left boston did i hear you move to
new york city or montreal i know i would
love to be in montreal i was in montreal
briefly no but i'm in new york city but
i would move to montreal like that
uh i guess maybe i mean i have i have
some family there um and i know a few a
few friends there but no quality of life
in canada is very high high to very high
um
yeah
i would completely consider moving to
canada it's funny when all when
everybody threatens to move to canada
after an election
it's like you know it's hard to move to
canada right you can't just show up and
move
um thank you to s prez for gifting
15 subscriptions
j crews for gifting another and ghost
rooster for gifting another that's 17
54
puts us at 71
71
an extraordinary
win
in the battle of ideas
uh yeah people acknowledging it is hard
to move to canada it really is it is
extraordinarily difficult to move to
canada hey david here's a poem i came up
with
for trump i call it a big massive
dumpties it goes like this
trumpy dumpty touted a wall trumpy
dumped these perfect phone call
now police forces and some policemen
will make it so trump cannot run again
have a great long weekend
very nicely done
you will have to ask the queen first to
move here
yes
all right folks here's the option you
have
okay here are your coupon code options
as you can see on the screen you can get
a mic pillow coupon code and get
yourself a pillow that's one option
okay option number one
second option
is you can get a membership on my
website with the coupon code indict
which includes the bonus show which alex
jones is furious about oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad you be the judge and tell me
which option is more auspicious
on an evening like tonight
do you know where the statement doj will
waited until after the midterms to
announce an indictment came from or if
there's anything to it yeah it's sources
who spoke to the media on the condition
of anonymity so take those for
what they are
sources who ask not to be identified
uh those are the sources on those
stories
how do you spell indict well it's right
there
it's right there
hey david
i love your show man and i'm i'm
watching
this live rally right now and uh
i've thought this before too man you're
just so freaking hilarious sometimes and
i i don't i don't know if people
appreciate your quick wit well thank you
but your expressions and i mean i mean
going by that the jesse lee peterson
interview
you're just freaking funny as hell dudes
i mean i agree with your your politics
pretty much
99.9 if not 100. i like this voicemail
but anyway keep doing what you're doing
man it's a
my favorite show
on cable or youtube
i appreciate that that's a caller from
nashville tennessee very very much
appreciated
hello it's uh jc colfax i'm calling from
bovo land in colorado
waiting for the trump rally to happen
and i'm very excited to be watching that
through you
except for i'm also extremely sad
because
don't you feel like this is the exact
beginning
of the next campaign
god help us all
thanks
a sad reality
a sad reality that is absolutely for
sure yeah
hi david this is steven calling back
again i called a couple other times
appreciate the show
what do you think the odds are that
trump has even more classified documents
that have yet to be realized or missing
yeah i am almost positive that's the
case in fact john bolton and michael
cohen both said the exact same thing
trump and listen
all of the empty folders mark top secret
he didn't take empty folders guys
he took folders with documents and the
documents are somewhere else it's of
course of course
regarding canada my girlfriend's
families from the philippines took years
to get approved to enter and six more
years for citizenship love you reese
says ian
important
important declaration the crowd seems
extra nutty today like they know the
walls are closing in but not until they
go out with one last bang one last rager
unfortunately that probably won't happen
anytime soon yeah the crowd seems extra
weaponized today and also trump running
late
seems to uh kind of wind them up even
more it's funny because when trump gets
there the speech half of the
three quarters of the speech is so
boring that the crowd it deflates when
trump actually gets there it's very
interesting very very interesting
i want to say thank you to trudy lamport
philip duncan
brenda b
for signing up on my website
joinpackman.com
putting us at 74. also thanks to juan
desiree de long and marjorie milner each
gifting a subscription really appreciate
the gifters as well putting us at 77
as we await failed former president
donald trump
i'd like i like in louisiana we always
have one rep republican and several
democrats independents on the ballot
this system only helps the republicans
and cuts
any real competition
all right thank you lee
for that message
uh more voicemails coming in
david sir you get a lot of grief
over your pronunciations and obviously
most of the time you're kidding but you
know honestly
if you hadn't told everyone that you
oh sorry you spoke english as a second
language and that you're you know your
first language is spanish
we wouldn't have had a clue at least i
would yeah guys
the reason why i struggle when i say dan
bongino
english is my second language and i'm
just doing the best i can to keep up
with with you know your hegemonic
imperialist language and sometimes i
make a mistake
sometimes i make a mistake and it
becomes difficult to pronounce certain
names like dan bongino
david your ability to keep a straight
face when speaking to lunatics is truly
masterful says kimberly thanks for the
laughs and keep up the good work thank
you kimberly and i'm glad to have you
here we are moments away as we have now
breached 12 000 live viewers across our
various platforms today
we are moments away from the failed
former president's first
speech
since
the fbi search warrant um
plans as sergey you have book
recommendations a book recommendation
page yeah if you want my financial book
recommendations you can go to
davidpakman.com
finance
if you want my other non-fiction
recommendations you can go to
davidpakman.com
nonfiction i think
non-fiction let me see
no that's incorrect
is it slash books i don't even know
where it is nope that's not it either
let me see if i can find it
okay davidpakman.com
recommendations
okay
and then you can find my economics
recommendations my narrative nonfiction
recommendations personal finance
philosophy and thinking books and
science books okay this is where all of
the different recommendations are it's a
beautiful thing
an absolutely beautiful beautiful thing
you can find those there
appreciate you david says matt well
thank you matt i appreciate you being
here and i have to tell you
i really appreciate folks who are coming
out of the woodwork today and signing up
on my website i want to say thanks to
james palashik or pale sheik
gina kehoe
june gibson
and jennifer hulack four new members on
my website and as always even though the
david pakman show and shows like ours
the young turks majority report etc we
have heavily male skewing audiences
during the live streams the ladies come
out of the woodwork with
the memberships and it is incredible
it is incredible and it is very much
appreciated
uh let's see if i have any other
voicemails to play
hey david so i know i know this is a
topic that you've discussed before but
uh i'd like to get your thoughts on this
again um i find it really really
annoying this sort of belief has become
popular over the years i'm not really
sure where it originated
about
big tax and how big tech
basically a handful of tech companies
most of the time social media companies
are not just companies but there's some
sort of evil
sort of
group that must get together once a year
and conspire and some sort of
super left wing uh
conference room somewhere probably in
san francisco on a street called marxist
avenue okay all right i get the picture
yeah i don't know where they get that
idea i don't know where they get that
idea but it's a very silly and kind of
dumb idea
can we can we agree on that is that fair
i'm curious let's see what right side
broadcasting is saying it's super easy
text trump to
989898 for that free information kit
that is a birch gold group because let
me tell you something with biden oh
they're selling gold okay so living gas
foods up for double digits
it's crazy and if that's got you crazy
then your investments have got to be
going crazy so move transfer out they'll
make it very simple to do that text
trump tonight your investments have got
to be going crazy
wasn't july one of the best months for
the stock market in like two years or
something completely maybe even longer
it was like nine up nine percent or
something like that what's it
it's like he doesn't even know he's like
i don't know joe biden's president
investments must be going crazy i don't
even know you get to get a gold coin or
something like that
uh wow all of president trump's rallies
and we've done that since 2015 we're
going to do it all the way up for as
long as president trump has rallied and
this yeah and i this is what i want to
happen right now i just got a message
from the rumble people right now the
views are trending up like you would not
imagine i want you to take this link
right now and go on your phone and
send it oh my god it they're trending
guys do you think they will find missing
documents in the ex-wife's coffin no i
don't think so i don't think so
cheers brother been watching a long time
your quality is consistent thanks dc
i bet you are a blast to have as a
partner smart men rock well thank you
june that's such a nice compliment i
appreciate that uh i don't know that my
girlfriend agrees but i appreciate it
the david pakman discord is super based
even if taffin from california doxxed
accidentally doxed one of his dates
and has awful opinions on movies oh boy
okay i don't know anything about that
um
ferret queen has been a member on
youtube for 24 months what should my
response be when someone claims the
student loan forgiveness will be paid
for by the taxpayers and cause inflation
uh tell them to wait and see and it
probably will not
hey pac-man have you heard of the right
winger
hugh
janus oh my god you got me
you got me no i haven't heard oh let me
google that where's hugh
very very adult now just so you guys
know most of the audience is between 24
and 54 okay they're not all 12 years old
just so everybody knows
i don't think the fed's mind if he keeps
running his mouth do you not at all i
think the feds are delighted to have
trump continue running his mouth
um
okay i want to say thank you to dr k
coffeynub and j
for the twitch subscriptions putting us
at 84. also want to say thank you to
jamie mccormack jamie mccormack just
signed up at joinpacman.com
and
is new member number 85 am i willing to
do a new coupon code
okay
what do people want as a coupon code
i mean indict is pretty on the nose
what are people looking for for a coup
i'll set one up why not just for us
today let's see let me pull up the page
it'll be an unpublished coupon code
mango no i don't know
let me see coupons
add new
i'm going to make this coupon code
criminal
we've never done this before
i'm going to make it a 71 percent
discount we've breached like 69 70
percent we've never hit a 71 percent
discount just for you guys because i
like you
gitmo
massive dumps empty folder no i'm not
seeing anything that really strikes my
fancy
45 prison flush
origins of the document no that's too
long
the thing about coupon codes is if
they're not easy to spell phonetically
people get people just miss it
mango mussolini no no no no no i don't
think people will like that
oh dark brandon you know what i think
i'm going to do that
dark brandon is the new hot thing that
the kids are telling me about let's make
that that the new coupon code today 71
off expires at midnight
available to you fine folks only is dark
brandon it is indeed live you can use it
at joinpackman.com i like that
honestly you know the funny thing about
dark brandon
i don't even know if i'm joking when i
when i talk about dark brandon
like i don't i'm not even sure if i'm
telling like if am i being satirical
when i talk about dark brandon i don't
know if it's all satirical
uh oh are the people starting to go nuts
let's see for watching this and sharing
it we appreciate all your help
seconds away from president trump taking
a stage here folks we are mere seconds
away look at the good time especially
this guy here in the red shirt is having
these people are really enjoying
themselves
really really really enjoying themselves
hard to believe but
they do seem to be
um as i am swiss in the heart of europe
just think of trump acting once more as
president in an ongoing ukraine conflict
unthinkable it is unthinkable
for as many free subscriptions as this
will pay for appreciate you very much
you keep a sane in this crazy world
thank you
hey david speaking of the feds how would
you react if they came out of nowhere
and arrested trump in the middle of his
hate rally yeah that's the third super
chat about that i have to tell you
if trump were arrested in the middle of
a rally i would love it now it's not
going to happen that way if trump is
indicted it will be arranged for him to
go with secret service he's not going to
be perp walked
david sir what do you think a dark
pacman meme would consist of i don't
know stephen but if people want to send
in their dark pacman memes i'm glad to
review them on the next stream
that's for sure
man look at these cult members give the
impression that he has their validation
that he is got the military behind him
to attack us the mega supporters all
right uh
break it down for me in the chat
do you believe that donald trump will do
his new favorite line tonight which is
teachers should not be allowed to teach
transgender will trump do the line
tonight what makes me doubt
is that trump might be on a completely
different racket because of the fbi raid
tell me in the chat will trump do the
teach transgender line today
it is
a real question
would be somewhat disappointed for trump
to be barred from office and divert
trump versus desantis civil war
that's a fair point
that's a fair trial yeah see this is a
dizzy juices in twitch chat is asking an
important question what happens with
secret service protection if trump goes
to prison
that's why if trump is indicted and if
trump ends up being convicted and if the
conviction includes some kind of
detention it would be served
at one of trump's houses it's just
it's just you can't there's no practical
way to put trump in prison and i've said
this before
i've said this before
david became a fan via your legendary
interviews with stephen kenneth destiny
bennell ii
hope all is well i have not checked in
with stephen for so long and i really
need to
maybe we'll have an opportunity soon
how could they identify as domestic
terrorists and not indict trump
good question
hey david as a member of an abrahamic
religion thoughts on red blood cells and
white and plasma in the human at the
moment of conception i have no thoughts
on that whatsoever
folks are starting to use our delightful
new coupon code dark brandon look at
these people signing up nick butler is a
new member
michael ransom is a new member andrew
tilly joshua dixon and zachary peake are
new members
william johnson has just signed up
oliver hernandez ralph corbin wow people
loving the dark brandon code stacey
murdo and katie gossett as well as scott
fleming wow
wow
that is nine additional people putting
us at 94 for the day and they keep
dumping in wow sean brenner using the
code
and joshua doig signing up
that puts us at 96 and a few gifted
subscriptions as well kevin combs
and
jason sickmeyer
very much appreciate that guys putting
us at 98. hey you know what new member
number 100 on the website i'll send you
a free item from my store whether you
want a coffee mug or whatever okay
that's only two away let's make it
happen tonight
sin sue says i'm a boomer born in 47
and it boggles the mind that my
generation the generation of the sexual
revolution civil rights marches war
protests and ecological awareness has
become full-blown magga sinsu i agree
with you
i agree with you it is desperately sad
desperately sad
emily says can you say hi to my daughter
harper lee she turned eight on august
29th and i find her watching you all the
time it's her first crush
keep up the good work sir emily thank
you
thank you
literally as dark orange
is emerging from a tunnel by the way
speaking of sir
today
at my favorite bagel shop in brooklyn
two families with tears in their eyes
were arguing over who gets to pay for my
bagel
it was unbelievable
unbelievable they were arguing with each
other who gets to pay
and i said you might want to wait and
see what i'm ordering first because i am
about to rack up a bagel bill that you
cannot even imagine
you cannot even imagine no in all
seriousness i got my standard saturday
bagel
which is
an everything bagel everything bagel
with
scallion cream cheese i love the
scallion
uh smoked salmon
pickled red onion
and a beautiful tomato slice a beautiful
tomato slice it's the best
all right folks
memberships who gets the free item
robin poignan and christana
gooden a daughter i believe that that's
an icelandic last name christanya you
are new member number 100 today and you
get a free item from my online store
please email in
also people just going crazy signing up
jeffrey belton lilly lee
i can't even keep up with the sign ups
so i will tally them once donald trump
starts speaking and i see the gifted
subscriptions on twitch i'm going to get
caught up on the number when donald
trump speaks it's just too much going on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the absurdity of these standing ovations
few other super chats to squeeze in
david keep doing what you're doing we
need you in these crazy times thank you
joan i appreciate that
david how are you i heard there's a
supreme court case on making police
brutality legal
i will have to look into that
could trump still get secret service
protection in prison i don't that sounds
weird i don't know
play proud to be an american play the
whole stone song stand there and look
innocent good job don
yeah uh let's see what trump has to say
first rally
since the raid
mexico and obama
and we will ban men
well thank you very much and hello
pennsylvania hello
good boy thrilled to be back in this
incredible commonwealth with the
thousands of proud hard-working
american patriots that i have gotten to
know so well
two months from now the people of
pennsylvania are going to fire the
radical left democrats and you are going
to elect doug mostriano as your next
governor
god i hope not
and you are going to send
my friend oz oh no
he is a great guy
to the u.s senate more muted applause
for us amazing slate of true america
first republicans to congress and we are
going to end
the nancy pelosi political career the
biden political career
we're going to end it our country's
going to hell
our country is going to hell
this election is a referendum on
skyrocketing
inflation rampant crime
soaring murders crushing gas prices
millions gas prices have declined faster
than ever in history across our border
race and gender indoctrination
perverting our schools and above all
this election
is a referendum on the corruption and
extremism
of joe biden and the radical democrat
party
can you imagine
if you want to stop this destruction of
america you must vote republican you got
to get out
as you know this week
joe biden came to
philadelphia pennsylvania to give
the most vicious hateful and divisive
speech
ever delivered by an american president
co-parter my friend
75 million citizens plus another
probably 75 to 150.
if we want to be accurate about it as
threats to democracy and as
trump thinks there's 225 million magats
in the united states enemy of the state
you want to know the truth the enemy of
the state is him and the group that
control him which is
circling around him do this do that joe
you're gonna do this joe right he's not
talking about the jews is he great
choice this isn't it is this an
anti-semitic thing he's doing
an anger his speech was hatred and anger
by the way the next morning he forgot
what he said you saw that
[Applause]
they asked him about oh i didn't think i
said that did i oh no
how'd you like the red lighting behind
him like the devil
i told you guys
i told you guys but philadelphia was a
great choice because the city is being
devastated under democrat rule
devastated hate to tell you it's fine we
love pennsylvania
i went to school in philadelphia what's
happening to philadelphia
14 people were shot last weekend in
philadelphia 14.
and the fake news will go out and check
oh that's a lot of fake news whoa
[Music]
that's a lot of fake news
it's only right-wing media at the speech
well they'll go out and check the facts
four people were killed last weekend at
one point last month seven people were
shot in the span of just
71 minutes philadelphia
this year in philadelphia has already
seen more than 1
400 people shot
including numerous beautiful little
children
last year the city set an all-time
murder record
with
560 homicides
and it's on track to shatter that record
again in 2022 numbers that nobody's ever
seen
other than
some other democrat
run cities
armed robberies in philadelphia are up
62 doug you have to take care of this
you have to take care of this
and oz will send you the goods oh god ah
send them the goods
you know what the goods are lots of
police officers that's what the goods
are
just recently announced retail theft
is up
59
from last year
there have been more than
750 carjackings this year anybody have a
nice car in the whole country that
sounds extremely low and triple the
average for 2010 to
2019 and it's heading way up heading up
in other cities that are run by
democrats oh and just in philly instead
of trying to demonize half of the
population biden
and congressional democrats should focus
on stopping the killing and the
bloodshed in philadelphia and every
other democrat
run city in america
where record death and destruction
is taking place every single day
biden thinks
making america great again
is bad for our country do you believe it
that was in his speech
my god
mega he says we've got to stop maga
that's when i defined it because i don't
think he knows what it meant it means
make america great again we have to stop
it
it seems to make to mean making
attorneys get attorneys that's really
the meaning of maga thanks making
america great again
is a threat to our country no making
america great again is great for our
country
there's only one party that's waging war
on american democracy by
censoring free speech
criminalizing dissent you see that
happening
disarming law abiding citizens
issuing lawless mandates and
unconstitutional orders
imprisoning
political protesters that's what they're
doing rigging elections they're called
insurrections weaponizing the justice
department and the fbi like never ever
before
and raiding and breaking into the homes
of their
political opponents i wonder who that
could be
[Applause]
republicans in the maga movement
are not the ones trying to undermine
our democracy we are the ones trying to
save our democracy very simple
very simple
very simple
the danger to democracy comes from the
radical left
not from the right
not from the right
i don't know trying to steal an election
you didn't win seems like a threat to
democracy to me tyranny of sickness
lawlessness and death
and we are going to take back our
country we're going to take it back
very powerful cult as you can all tell
there could be no more vivid example of
the very real threats from
american freedom than just
a few weeks ago you saw it threats from
american freedom shocking abuses of
power by any
administration
in american history here we go the
shameful raid and break-in of my home
mar-a-lago
was a travesty of justice
[Applause]
[Music]
that made a mockery of
america's laws traditions and principles
before the entire world the entire world
was watching
and auto they're shocked
[Applause]
south american countries
numerous of them their leaders said
could you imagine
if that was ever done in our country
what the united states would be saying
about us
the biden administration invaded the
home of their chief political opponent
who is absolutely destroying him and
everyone else in the polls i so trump's
not running for anything
biden had nothing to do with it and the
polls are pretty close
even including the republicans but we
love the republicans
on a phony pretext
getting permission from a highly
political magistrate
who they hand-picked late in the evening
just days before the break-in
and trampled upon my rights and civil
liberties as if our country that we love
so much
we're a third world nation
so it's basically a me me me speech
[Applause]
they rifled through the first lady's
closet drawers and everything else
they pulled out her bras
and they found documents in there which
they planted
of the room of my sixteen-year-old son
leaving everything they touched in far
different condition than it was
when they started uh-oh can you believe
it
the fbi and the justice department have
become vicious monsters
controlled by radical left scoundrels
lawyers and the media who tell them what
to do you people right there and when to
do it what a victim
they're trying to silence me and more
importantly they are trying to silence
you but we will really not be silenced
right the fbi which is investigating
possible trump crimes is trying to
silence the people in the crowd that
doesn't make any sense
usa usa but not the house the senate the
fbi the uh the justice department
we have no choice because we're not
going to have a country left
the evil and malice of this demented
persecution
of you and me
should be obvious to all and it is even
media companies that are pretty far left
have come out and said we can't believe
this is happening in the usa
we are being assaulted by the same group
at the fbi and doj
that just a few years ago declared no
reasonable prosecutor would charge
crooked hillary clinton
after she set up a secret illegal server
to hide her family's pay for play
schemes
crammed it full of classified
information allowed it to be
plundered by foreign hackers you know
that happened
and then deleted
acid-wise
30 000
emails think of that
he's still on the acid wash stuff
and what else did she do
boom with a hammer smashed her phone
systems to smithereens
after receiving the highest level of
subpoena from the u.s congress
guys they're for law and order
and due process
and locking up hillary who has not even
been charged with anything
dangerous
this is the danger to democracy my
friends
think of that
think of that
yet now these same people the exact same
people
are sending the fbi storming through the
home of their number one political rival
it's a disgrace a disgrace like
possibly never before our country's
never seen anything like that all right
guys is hunter's laptop coming up not
being properly stored
yet they go in and take documents dump
them on the floor
stage a photo shoot dumps
and pretend that i had done it like i
had put them all over the floor
they took that back
after a lot of prodding
then they put out for public consumption
a picture
which is seen all over the world this is
what they do it's called disinformation
these are very
dishonest
sick people
the people in the crowd he means
very dishonest people
americans are sick of the lies sick of
the hoaxes and scams and above all sick
of the hypocrisy
but our opponents have badly
miscalculated
this egregious abuse of the law is going
to produce a backlash
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
before this is the violence code
this is the coded violence stuff
before our very eyes our beloved country
is being taken over by the very people
who turn democracies into dictatorships
and into ultimately ruination
they think they can divide us but they
can't okay can't divide us they can't
divide us
the maga movement
is the greatest
in the history
of our country
if you're just joining us this is a
rally in support of dr oz and doug
mastriano that's the funniest thing
about it and he has he's barely
mentioned them
in the history of the world maybe in the
history of the world
in any event we have no choice
we are trying to save our country
because
such bad things are happening
to our
beautiful beloved america
we will
make america great again
i will never turn my back on you
and you will never turn your back on me
because we love our nation
and we will save our nation from people
who are trying to
destroy it
it was not just
my home
that was raided last month
it was the hopes and dreams of every
citizen who i've been fighting for since
the moment i came down the golden
escalator give me a break dude
in 2015
wanting to represent the people
wanting to stop the massive corruption
of our country
and determined to finally
in this world put
america first i want to put america
first delusions of grandeur
we did there's never been a period of
time
both before covet or the china virus as
we say and after covert
china
from that moment on i became the enemy
of the washington swamp
for six years the radical democrat party
the rhinos the media and the deep state
have tried relentlessly to stop me and
you
first they fabricated the
russia-russia-russia scam you saw it was
a total fabrication yeah what was it 34
people indicted 47 people something like
that
then we had impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two and now
these same exact people at justice and
the fbi the same people along with
outside scum
are at it again
with the horrific
raid of
my home
they just go on and on
and they have to be stopped
we have to spend time on our country not
on defending ourselves against scams
thank you
[Applause]
think of it about russia and the mueller
no collusion
right came in no collusion
that was your decision after two and a
half years no collusion i could have
told them that after the first hour and
they could have
said that because they had the laptop
from hell which had everything so they
knew immediately
but it went on but think of this you
know when i tell the story on a kick
wait a second they had hunter's laptop
for the mueller report i don't i don't
remember that that being the timeline
does that does anybody remember that
it was developed
by hillary clinton and a group of people
small group around a kitchen table
as a way of explaining why she lost an
election that a lot of people thought
she would win because the democrats have
an advantage in elections because of a
lot of things aside from the fact they
cheat like hell
so when they lost
hillary clinton and her people and
guys like
adam shifty schiff
watermelon
watermelon head he's a water purple
he's a watermelon head
but no dummy
[Applause]
but think of this think how bad they are
think how evil they are you're all
fathers and your mothers and your
children of great people and all of the
people are represented here think how
bad they are
they make up a story that's false it's
now been admitted to be false
the fbi is the last one to tell us that
but it's now admitted even in the
newspapers even by the people back there
they will not fight it
they make up now think of this
but think of this
[Applause]
so they make up a story about russia
just so you know i was tougher in russia
than any president before i'm the one
that stopped nordstrom 2 the pipeline
i'm the one that did the big sanctions
what a
liar and i guarantee you one thing putin
was not going into ukraine i guarantee
you that
i guarantee you nobody was tougher than
me but i also got along with them and
it's a good thing you know getting along
with other countries
is a good thing not a bad thing but
think of it so they make up a story
russia russia russia
it was made up
so that when they lost they could say it
was russia
i'm saying what the hell did russia have
to do with it it was russia
okay so adam schiff knows it's a fake
story he made it up with other people
they know it's a fake and i see adam
shift
are you guys following this story bones
in the capitol building
and stand there so sad
and say
donald
trump jr
will be going to prison
because of what he did
with russia now think of it he knows the
story's a scam he knows the stories of
fake and he wants my son who's a good
kid he wants me 40 something to go to
prison over something that they made up
that they know is a phony story and has
now been as they say fully debunked in
other words it was a totally and he's a
small innocent child
with many of those people standing there
and they can't get enough
saying that my son
is going to prison and i then call my
son i say
don are you okay what's going on
what's going on think of this if you're
a parent think of it
my son's going to prison on something
that they made which is a total hoax
these are bad people they're trying to
destroy our country and we can't let it
go on any longer because we have too
much work to do yeah trump's
95 of the audience is understandably
confused the other five percent realizes
trump is mixing and mashing together
different conspiracy theories first
attorney generals these state attorney
generals if i fly over a state they send
me before a grand jury there's trump
he's up there let's see what can we do
with a grand jury i've been going
through this for six years now
local democrat d.a's county prosecutors
congressional committees or federal
agencies the radical democrats are
engaging in a desperate attempt to keep
me from returning to the white house
where they know i will clean this mess
up again
just like he did those first four years
and god bless
the united states
they want to stop us
from completing our mission to bring
back
american values
secure
america's borders
millions and millions of people are
pouring into our country nobody has any
idea where they're from
last month
129
countries
were represented they're emptying their
prisons into the united states of
america
not happening
they know we'll continue to fix
america's trade deals
continue to lower taxes nobody gave tax
decreases like trump bigger than the
reagan cuts
and lower regulations that created all
of those jobs defend and protect our
police and our military
we have to protect our police you know
our police want to protect us
they're stymied from doing it
we have to protect our police
meanwhile they want the doj and fbi
completely taken apart and defunded
we're going to save our second amendment
which is under siege
we build our manufacturing base
just like i was doing in other words
they know that we're going to make
america great again you know
we had a different saying because
after we did so well we were all set
and we had a statement remember keep
america great
but after they destroyed it i'd love to
use it
but i must say there's nothing like
magga you're good
i don't know doug
i don't know cag
tag wasn't the same as magga i got gas
keep america great the problem i had
though wasn't the fact that kag can't
compete with mega the real problem i had
that
we can't use the word keep america great
because they've destroyed our country
so we can't keep it great because it's
not great right now our country is a
laughingstock
our leaders are a laughing stock
you know we just sent another 13 billion
to ukraine that gets us close to 80
billion dollars now
well it angers me more for a different
reason it would have never happened
before putin knew he wouldn't have done
it he said vladimir you're not going to
do it ed vladimir he knew that he knew
it he knew it but that never happened as
soon as
the election was rigged and it was
considered over i don't know if it's
ever going to end if you look at what's
gone on
because more and more facts are coming
out oh yeah the fbi with facebook the
other day any day now it's all going to
come out
our country
it would have been so inappropriate to
say keep america great because who the
hell wants to keep our country the way
it is right now i
don't
yeah there's too many dangerous
right-wing extremists he's right beaten
every single witch-hunt in the past
think of that
but the time and the money and the
effort it takes
and now we will likewise do that in the
future if they continue their craziness
and if they don't stop they don't stop
that's all they're good at is
disinformation they put out
disinformation you know what i heard
about russia
was right after i came down that
beautiful golden escalator
first lady i said uh you'll be a great
first lady she has been a great person
she's been a great first lady
they love our first lady
but people would come up to me this was
right at the beginning and
right after the escalator ride that
people go sure do you know anything
about russia sir oh some guys come up
beautiful staffers there are a lot of
them here right now and here all over
the place that just came up to me you
won pennsylvania by a lot sir that's
right you're right about that sir
doug i think at nine o'clock in the
evening
we were 950 000 votes up with 73 of the
vote cast all of a sudden around 302 or
something
the equipment closed down
it all closed down and then you had that
massive spike remember the spike that
went to heaven and came back it should
have gone to hell and come back
and all of a sudden we were tied and
then all of a sudden we lost by a
whisper
a rigged election he really has a way of
telling these stories that you just you
just feel it huh sir
it's such an honor to meet you sir sir
can i ask you a question you can't wait
sir
do you know anything about russia
say no not really i know probably less
than you know
but i have a lot of common sense and i
know how to defend our country and i'll
end up being friendly with them and
we'll do just fine oh good god then a
month later another one came up hello
uncle sam look at it stand up uncle sam
great people
great people
then a month later another young person
came up
a little naive and said and i was very
actually was cute
he said
oh it's such an honor sir
she said sir can i ask you one question
that's been bothering me yeah what is it
do you know anything about russia
and then again and again and after about
five or six times
i looked at my people my
top people that are a little older i
said what the hell is going on with
russia
this is all i knew what was going on
it was just none of this ever happened
right two and a half years
to win
but all of that time and effort and
money and the corruption and the people
that were in charge of that scam are
horrible and they're the same people
that we have now they never leave they
never leave and if we would have had
an attorney general with courage instead
of somebody that was afraid to be
impeached sir i don't want to be a peace
we would have gotten to the bottom of it
very quickly
and we've been waiting for durham for a
long time durham please come in and give
us your work please
durab durham we got to get durham the
country really is waiting for durham
with bated breath it's not about me this
is a struggle for the very fate of our
republic
our movement is fighting against a
corrupt group of unelected tyrants who
believe they can by the way when does he
get to the endorsement of oz and
mastriano like is that even part of this
speech corrupt media
they think the deep state
not the citizens
should be the true masters of this
country uh-oh
deep state on our watch
we will never let that happen and we
will never
let it happen even though we're going to
be gone we're going to set this country
up so strong and so powerfully that we
may not be here at least some of the
older ones that i love you all but we're
going to have the country set up
properly like it was before the covet
came in before the china dust came in
and even after we hand it off
that is a freaking credible idea where
we had a higher stock market
because we did it twice
but we had a higher stock market
on january 20th than we did think of it
the so-called handoff i hate to even use
the term it's so ridiculous it's so
ridiculous to have to use that term
but the handoff we handed it off the
market was higher than it was just prior
to covid coming into our country we did
an incredible job incredible job
but we have no choice in 2022 and 2024
we have to smash the grip of this vile
and vindictive political class we have
to clean house in washington d.c and we
have to restore government for the
people
you think the women and and well i guess
it's mostly women but yeah well of
course uh moms for masteriano you think
they're kind of like why isn't he
talking about masteriano we're here to
hear about that we do not our republic
and indeed our country will be destroyed
and we will never be able
to do what is called a comeback you
won't be able to do it it'll never come
back again
it's so fragile you know it's so fragile
you will never bring it back again
you remember in the campaign i used to
say if these people get in we're going
to end up with venezuela on steroids i
said it many many times and that's what
we have as much of a possibility but i
never knew people could cheat like that
not like that
last week
weirdo
is a weirdo mark zuckerberg came to the
white house kissed my ass
kiss my uh sir i've looked after them
sir i'd love to have dinner i'd love to
bring my lovely wife i don't even know
what i'm doing all right mark come on in
sir your wife is up there you're number
one on facebook i'd like to congratulate
you oh thank you very much mark i
appreciate it
weirdo mark zuckerberg confessed that in
2020
the fbi went to facebook and the media
and gave them the false narrative that
the hunter biden laptop from hell
was russian disinformation
even though
they knew that was not true so they went
then they said it was russian
disinformation by the way
the guy that came in with that stuff
just got fired he perk walked he was
perk walked out of the fbi on friday
but that doesn't help us and the
election
of 2020 does it that doesn't help us
they perk walked him because of all the
things he did so many more than what
we're even talking about
the fbi made it clear that they did not
want the truth about the criminality and
influence peddling of the biden family
coming out before the election because
that would hurt the chances of joe biden
who virtually never left his basement
winning the election
how embarrassing is it
that without leaving his basement biden
got eight million more votes it's the
most humiliating defeat for trump
and we have a lot of people in this
place
and a lot of people
wow
[Music]
what a big boy you only lost by 8
million to a guy who didn't leave his
basement right we got a lot of people
outside watching i hope they're watching
the big we put screens up outside
you know this place i think it holds 12
000 people so we're sold out in about 15
seconds and yeah there's a bunch of
empty seats people
that can't get in that's why a lot of
times i like fields because fields you
could just keep having them in alabama
we had 66 000 people think of this
outside of you did you call it abadama
had 89 000 people show up think of it
i think there's a million people in that
place to be perfectly frank and election
interference on a scale
that we have never seen before in our
country
according to pollsters
it made a 10
to 20 point difference not even
including all of the other totally
determinative evidence of illegality
that was found having to do with the
2020 presidential election scam
including ballot stuffing and not
adhering
to the laws rules and regulations of
state legislatures which is totally
illegal
they just did whatever they wanted to do
and frankly
the ballots were reportedly stuffed with
a gorgonzola prosciutto cream and it was
completely criminal else
should be ashamed of himself and a guy
like mitch mcconnell
who allowed this stuff to happen
should be scorned he should be scorned
the 2020 election was rigged and stolen
and now our country is being destroyed
by people who got into office through
cheating and through fraud
now watch the cameras will all turn off
as soon as i say that because they're
not allowed to put that on it's only
right-wing nut media there they're not
turning the camera off they'll all turn
off they don't want to hear that
they don't want to hear that you know
why
but republican leadership just doesn't
fight because in many cases
they are intimidated and they're afraid
they're actually afraid
republicans must get tougher and
stronger and fast
by the way i'll tell you a guy that
fought
in fact that's why he's here today is
your nominee
doug mastriano he fought
he tried to steal the election
but he was dealing with rhinos and all
sorts of crap
but doug you fought like very few people
for it that's really why he's here
because everybody saw that he fought you
know after people figured it out they
all ran on the basis of we're gonna stop
but they were not there he was there at
the beginning and the people understood
it so it's a big deal
and by the way i saw a poll today doug
you said you're tied or up one point
just so you know again
all they do well is cheat on elections
and use disinformation
so when he's running he's got a big base
and he won by a lot he won by even more
when i endorse him but that's okay so
trump's been speaking about 38 minutes
let me know in the chat will trump go
over 90 minutes today or will he stay
under 90 minutes today when he was doing
well he was way up and he had a big base
and they don't like that so what do they
do the one we really want to run against
is doug mostriano that's the one well
they say that on every time they have
somebody that's going to kick their ass
they go out and they say the one we want
to run again the one person they didn't
want to run against is doug
mostriano it's disinformation
true
[Music]
i kept hearing it i'd be out i'd see the
people going crazy for doug
for his incredible wife
[Applause]
but it's true
true he was right there from the
beginning day one
got to fight the republicans and the
democrats you had to fight people
american elections should be determined
only by the american people
and that did not happen in 2020 and i'm
just talking to fbi but there are many
many other things we won't go into it
the mar-a-lago raid thank you was a
desperate effort to distract from joe
biden's record of misery and failure
the many disasters that our country in
the world can you imagine gas prices
plummeting inflation down two
spectacular job reports in a row full
employment
it's a it's a dystopia out there folks
take the five worst presidents in
american history and put them together
and they would not have done the damage
joe biden has done to our country in
less than two years they could not have
done it
two years ago when i was in office
gas was
1.87 cents i guess i got gas
and we weren't talking about going to
all electric cars which are twice as
expensive i mean the problem is a friend
of mine wanted to do something for the
environment he went out and bought a
electric car
and he made a certain trip i won't say
from where kentucky i won't say from him
and he's a good person he wants to do
what's well now he understands
not so good and he bought an electric
car and he made the trip often from
kentucky to washington and he made it
and he'd drive down and
put the car away and drive back
he was getting like 38 miles a gallon
and who's fine and then he goes to
hybrids and all the other things they
can do
but he wanted to go all electric because
he wants to save our country once i save
the atmosphere and he called me he said
i'm exhausted why
he said this damn trip
took me forever i'd drive for two hours
and then i'd have to have my car charged
and in two cases i couldn't find a place
to charge it but even if i could it took
me more time to charge the damn car that
i could spend in it driving
he said it took me two and a half times
please please let's get rid of this
stuff
please and you see in california
you see what's happening there where
they're going all electric cars
number one people can't afford them
number two the batteries are made all in
china all the earth the rare earth come
you can go from louisville to washington
dc
which is normally a 9 hour and 25 minute
trip
with just 49 minutes of tesla
supercharging uh and that's pretty damn
far i mean it'll take you 10 hours and
10 minutes instead of 9 hours and 25
minutes
doesn't sound too crazy to me
china
by the way in nine and a half hours
you're probably stopping for at least
one full meal anyway don't make a deal
with russia
on the pipeline and they said oh that's
so funny i actually sent during a
meeting g7 i sent angela angela merkel
a white flag of surrender she said
donald donald but why do you send me
this white flag i said angela
because you're going to surrender 75 of
your energy is coming from russia if you
look back over the decades
russia and germany haven't done too well
together
when there's a war when there's a
problem they'll just turn off
north stream two and back in five you're
not gonna be able to defend yourselves
oh that will never happen well that was
about two years ago
the only thing i never thought it was
going to happen this fast and now
they're giving me great remember i made
the speech at the united nations and the
german delegation was all smiling they
thought it was so funny they're not
smiling now he said it better than me
they're not smiling now
but now gas is five dollars and six
dollars and seven dollars and it's gonna
be going up
think of it
and they brag because it came down
slightly you know it came down about 42
cents
we actually had it down at one point to
a dollar 42 remember that but i had to
get it a little up we had to let the oil
companies make a couple of bucks i
didn't want to wipe out the oil
companies
but what's happened is one of the big
reasons for inflation is what this guy
has done with energy because energy's so
all-encompassing it's so big
with the help of pennsylvania energy
workers
did you get screwed or what
remember i told you they were going to
do this to you
he lied during the debate he said no no
i would never do that
the first thing he did practically
was end the keystone pipeline right that
was like the first thing he did
and you know all those workers voted for
me but the head of the union voted for i
wonder is he still the head checking out
he ought to be fired real fast
the keystone pipeline would have been
great a lot of jobs that would have done
a good job
with the help of pennsylvania energy
workers under my leadership we had
american energy independence for the
first time ever
ever
and within a short period of time we
would have been energy dominant we would
have been bigger
than russia
and saudi arabia combined times two and
now
we're beggars
[Applause]
we're like a beggar nation we gave you
think of that we're energy beggars we
would have been bigger than everybody
combined the two biggest
the biggest energy
suppliers combined times two
we're going to be energy dominant and
now we're beggars
we gave you the largest tax cuts and
regulation cuts
in american history the radical democrat
congress just passed one of the largest
tax hikes
in american history pulverizing
the middle class and now you have the
privilege of
having 87 000 irs agents
go after you
and they've actually been approved i'd
never heard of this one they got
approved to carry guns
so they can go after you with guns you
know they don't want to have guns but
it's okay for the irs it's like an army
can you imagine that that was approved
that they allowed that to get through
and all mitch mcconnell had to do
is waive their debt ceiling i'm not
approving anything
having to do with debt ceiling unless
you drop all this crap four trillion
dollars worth because mansion folded
like a dog you saw that and i always
said he would i told you he would he did
and west virginia which voted for me 45
points i was up 45 points west virginia
is not happy with joe manchin because he
killed cole and they put taxes on call
clean beautiful coal he killed it i
can't imagine he's going to do well i
don't know what the hell got to him
under the trump administration we had
the greatest economy in the history of
the world with no inflation
biden and the democrat congress
created the worst inflation in 50 years
9.1 that is going to go a lot higher
and now they are
making it worse with their immoral plan
to wipe out hundreds of billions of
dollars of debt
for college graduates now think of this
how unfair is it how unfair is it to all
of those people many of you are here
that paid and worked so hard i saw they
were
doing a story about pocahontas that's
elizabeth warren from massachusetts oh
god with that now and this big strong
guy came up to her really a good
good-looking guy
and he looks at her gonna say well
what's going on with the stet you want
to cancel the debt i've been working my
ass off for 12 years he said and i've
almost got my daughter's debt paid off i
worked weekends 12 years my neighbor
he's my friend but he hasn't worked at
all
and now the debt's going to be canceled
but i worked this is unfair and then he
was not too nice after that so we'll
forget what he said but he was not too
happy
but you can multiply that times millions
and millions of people
they paid for it on the backs of man the
crowd is riveted what an electric
speaker he says remember this you don't
realize it you're getting the biggest
tax increase in history it's all
disinformation they're saying under
under 400 000 you're getting the biggest
tax increase in the history of our
country so enjoy paying it
and you know what it's paying for things
very much untrue new deal which is like
taking the money and throwing it out the
window and it's actually they've not
done the geriniu deal i mean i don't
know what he's talking about our country
because it sets us back
just like germany you know germany's
back to building and opening its plants
because they got so
screwed up with their green new energy
they got carried away windmills all over
the place killing all the birds
destroying all the values of homes
destroying the plains and fields
beautiful plains if you want to see
a dead bird cemetery go under a windmill
sometime it's not a pretty you literally
paint one of the blades of the wind farm
and you reduce the number of dead birds
dramatically and also the fossil fuel
industry kills way more animals than
wind farms china
and germany to a lesser extent
i rebuilt our military including our
nuclear capability and hope to god we
never have to use it
and the creation of space force do you
see what they're doing with iran
iran was dying to make a deal with me i
would have had a deal done within one
week after the election
and now we're going to pay them hundreds
of billions of dollars and they're going
to have nuclear weapons within a short
period of time
these people are crazy because they're
correct i mean they honestly
they can't be stupid they must hate our
country they must hate our country they
surrendered our strength and our
wisdom our everything
they turned afghanistan into the
greatest humiliation
our country has ever seen i believe it
was the most humiliating
thing time
that the country has ever gone through
13 dead soldiers but they never
mentioned those soldiers who lost their
legs and arms and what do you think the
crowd the people in the crowd say when
they go home like man what a great
speech i really liked it when trump said
russia citizens behind
and we left 85 billion dollars worth of
the best military equipment in the
entire world planes and tanks and
goggles
700 000 rifles and
8k 47s
we left it all behind think of this
70 000 vehicles
there's not a used car lot in the
country that has probably 500 vehicles
70 000 vehicles we left behind some
women's vehicles cost millions of
dollars because they're armor players
honestly all those people look bored i
think a lot of people like the idea of a
trump speech and then for 90 minutes he
tells stories that go in circles and
they go this isn't as good as i thought
free equipment
and you know i saw a number the other
day
the second largest arms dealer in the
entire world
is afghanistan
because they're selling because they
don't need 700 000 rifles
and guns 700 000
they need
40 000 or 20 000
what were we thinking you don't take the
military out first
and remember this in afghanistan
18 months we didn't lose one soldier you
heard the numbers on philadelphia
18 months
i spoke to abdul i said abdul don't do
it after here go to don't do it but why
sir why do you send me a picture of my
house i said abdul that's a different
story
don't do it
and we were fine remember they said why
is he speaking to the taliban because
that's where the problem was right
that's where the problem was
18 months and biden actually said it a
couple of months ago well i'll say one
thing we uh didn't lose uh one soldier
in 18 months and they're screaming at
him you
don't take it back
you're not supposed to say that because
it's good hey big shout out by the way
to office drummer who just subscribed on
twitch i i've recommended office
drummers drumming content and i
apologize for saying he was dressed like
a generic office worker it's called
business casual and that was a mistake
but anyway check out office drummer on
twitch and also youtube now we're away
from where china makes its nuclear
weapons we should have never left
without keeping bagram
what a shame the most humiliating time i
believe actually that probably putin
went in because when he saw the
incompetence of that yes or no trump
says muslims during today's speech yes
or no russia and ukraine with
potentially hundreds of thousands and
even
millions of people are going to die
that would have never happened if i was
your president it would have never
happened i promise you i talked to him
vladimir you can't do that can't do it
vladimir
those beautiful golden turrets in moscow
vladimir i want to leave them alone
please
do it vladimir he would never have done
it is he talking about turrets what does
he mean terrets
is he talking about tarot cards on
nordstrom 2 nobody thought that was
possible i ended north can you imagine
biden came in and he opened up the
pipeline i ended it
then he'd say oh trump was soft on
russia i was soft the only one that
doesn't think that is putin
he didn't think i was too soft with the
sanctions but think of it the biggest
deal they've ever done
is nordstrom 2 that nobody ever heard
i'm guessing soon the rally for doug
mastriano and dr oz starts right i mean
it must he's been speaking for an hour
it must be about to start the safest
border in united states history
[Applause]
[Music]
we deported record numbers of illegal
aliens this is a critical moment in that
woman's life hundreds and hundreds of
miles of border wall
despite two and a half years of democrat
inspired
lawsuits we had 11 lawsuits i won every
one of them took two and a half years to
win
and you know we completely finished
our original plan for the wall
and they came to me sir we have they
finished the plan that's a that's an
amazing little shift there he's been
saying for years the wall is done now
he's saying would they finish the plan
for the wall anybody can finish the plan
this guy it's like having a reservation
for a car but never getting the car you
had the plan great to use the stuff that
was sitting there ready to be that's
genius erected it was going to be
erected very quickly very very very
effectively great great wall it's
exactly what border patrol wanted i said
what do you want this is exactly they
want steel
they wanted concrete they wanted a rebar
heavy set rebar they wanted exactly and
they have to be able to see through so
we see what's happening on the other
side
i want to just give a nice big beautiful
concrete plank but they didn't want that
so we gave them exactly what they wanted
and they could have been finished in a
few weeks by the way this is the wall
they built a little section of and
people were defeating it with a hundred
bucks worth of stuff from an average
hardware store not even a good hardware
store just from an average hardware
store thing
three weeks was all it would have taken
to complete the job our country is
paying a terrible price
three weeks for the rigged election
i ran twice i won twice and did much
better the second time than i did the
first
getting millions and millions more votes
in 2020 than we got in 2016. the guy in
the let's go brandon shirt is delivering
a standing ovation
you know that
doug knows that my favorite thing that
trump does by the way trump criticized
obama using a teleprompter for years
trump uses a teleprompter my favorite
thing is trump reads he doesn't even
pretend it's his speech
he reads the prompter and then reacts to
it like he'll look over and he'll go
this is the most dangerous time in
american history
that's true it is he reacts he's
commenting clearly on a speech that is
not his and likewise getting more votes
than think of it
there's never been a president a sitting
president got anywhere near
i think we got like 10 million more
votes than obama got obama you know
so popular
so popular
he's so popular they say he's so
handsome oh obama's so happy
he's such a great speaker what does he
say
he says nothing
and we're leading
biden and everything that's called
projections so trump's uh self-esteem
clearly is uh such that trump feels bad
that obama is both more handsome and a
better speaker
do it again
where is
is oz even allowed here
may just have to do it again
and we will ban men
but first we have to win
a historic victory
for the republican party this november
oz couldn't make the rally because he's
where he really lives which is a
different state mayor joe biden and
congressional democrats have created on
our southern border a nightmare
remember this we had the strongest best
border we ever had two years ago now we
have the worst border i believe it's
worse than any border anywhere in the
world
because no third world country would let
people come into their country our
border is worse than the disputed area
in kashmir last year
two illegal alien criminals allegedly
brutalized
and bludgeoned a man to death bit of a
glitch there
street corner
in chester county an illegal alien
stands accused of grabbing a 33 year old
woman by the hair
pulling her down and around the ground
and stabbing her to death in front of
her seven-year-old daughter and her
three-year-old son
and just a few weeks ago an illegal
alien murderer
was charged with shooting to death a 76
year old man
from pennsylvania
he took a walk every morning and this
guy
killed him for no reason whatsoever
didn't know him by the way i know dr oz
is there i'm just kidding around
just a joke
the radical democrat congress has turned
our country into one giant
sanctuary for dangerous criminal aliens
we protect all of the criminals we don't
protect our own people in fact
they raid our people
in the republican party we believe our
country should be a sanctuary
for law abiding citizens who love
america
[Applause]
if we're going to make america great
again
our first task is to
make america safe again we have to have
a safe country
we have to have a safe place
and you know
i told you before i love the fields but
i like these better because the air
conditioning system but this air
conditioning is not working too well
it's about 100 degrees up here
[Applause]
i'm sweating like a dog but i'm
i'll call dr oz dr oz am i okay doctor
am i okay he says and the combat
infection
in arizona show years ago
and uh dr raz i'm going to introduce him
in a second but i was on the show years
ago
and
he did like an examination of me i don't
know what the hell i did to show for i
wasn't like even a politician at that
point but he did
an examination and the word said
he's extremely healthy really a very
very fine fit man but
he should lose 20 or 25 pounds i was so
angry i didn't speak to him for you
an examination he said he was great but
he could lose a couple of pounds
he's great he's going to be great
under democrat control the streets of
our great cities are drenched in the
blood of innocent victims much of this
crime is caused by drug dealers
who during the course of their lives
will kill an average of 500
american citizens every drug dealer is
responsible can you think of a more
absurd statistic that's obviously a lie
than that but families that are just
devastated by what happened to their
children and to themselves think of it
500 people
the average
drug dealer i'm calling for the death
penalty for drug dealers which will upon
expansion
reduce drug trump wants even harsher
penalties for for drug-related crimes
interesting
this is this is like straight-up duterte
stuff
no more blue ribbon committees telling
us what to do
you know
i was setting them up in the white house
there's a blue ribbon committee headed
by socialites
and they just want i mean look they're
very nice people but
they just want a little publicity for
themselves they can't deal with the kind
of killers that we're talking about
we want the death penalty for drug
dealers and you will save
millions of lives you know we're going
to lose 250 000 people i think this year
this is all kind of dumb because most
drug crimes are state-level crimes and
like it's just it's so stupid for a guy
who would even be running for president
to be talking about it
on a beautiful saturday evening
then a trump rally
no more drop by
i don't think
trump route
but just to go for a second so you know
i got to know a lot of the foreign
leaders and let me tell you uh unlike
our
leader uh they're at the top of their
game these are like central casting
there's nobody that could play
the role in hollywood all of hollywood
nobody can play the role of president xi
of china
nobody could play the role he's a fierce
person
putin fierce he's smart you know a lot
of times i'll say somebody's smart and
the fake news will go he called
president xi smart
he rules with an iron fist 1.5 billion
people yeah i'd say he's smart wouldn't
you say he's smart
so
i'm with president xi and i got along
with him very well i mean once coveted
came it was just so but we made a great
trade deal with them helped our farmers
helped our manufacturers but i'm with
them
and
i really had a great relationship with
him and then
i asked him a question i said uh
president he's president for life by the
way so i call him king i say king
he said but i am not king i said you are
to me you're president for life it's the
same thing what you will be very soon
you know they're having another by the
way do you notice a lot of ships are
circling taiwan that wouldn't have
happened either by the way
but i said president could i ask you a
very simple question
do you have a drug problem he looked at
me like
what's wrong with that no of course not
he goes no no he's like
what the hell stupid question is uh
i know all the time i said you don't
have a drug problem with 1.5 billion
people china his big problem is they
make the drugs they send them into our
country that's their problem that would
have been their problem and he was
stopping it too but now they're sending
the fentanyl in at numbers that you
wouldn't believe wouldn't believe it
pouring through that porous border at
numbers you wouldn't believe i had them
very close to stopped i couldn't do it i
told him you can't do it
so president
president
you don't have a drug problem but why
but why don't you have a drug problem
bro uh we have quick trial
i said what is a quick trial
we immediately catch
the drug dealer
we give him quick trial
and if he is guilty which i would say
probably they're batting would you say
oz would you say they're about batting a
hundred percent or only 99. like russia
yeah the drug dealer is guilty yeah 99
conviction rate like russia have no drug
problem in china
and they have other countries like that
too it's amazing how great the police
are at figuring out exactly who did the
crime that they have such a high
uh conviction rate calling for the death
penalty itself but think of it
they kill 500 people during a lifetime
and i think it's much worse than that i
think that's only what we hear about
it would stop it i i if you didn't get
it down 75 80 90 from day one i'd be
surprised
and these committees that they set up
it's laughable it's a horrible thing we
would solve that problem so fast and i'm
calling on republicans and democrats
immediately to institute to get to
washington and institute the death
penalty for drug dealers you will no
longer have
i don't know that washington can do
anything it's these are state crimes
can anybody weigh in
so philadelphia has become as you heard
many times over the last short period of
time
worse than it's ever been it's become a
killing field a few days ago
a four-year-old boy was shot while
getting a haircut
for his first day
in school his mother was so proud of him
he was getting a hot he was shot
recently a pregnant mother
was shot in the head and horribly
murdered
her unborn baby was
miraculously saved under a republican
congress we should pass emergency
funding to hire thousands and thousands
more police officers nationwide
to put violent criminals behind bars and
keep them
behind bars
and also
leave our police
alone
let them do other than the capitol
police
and the fbi
and the doj who are all doing terrible
things and should be fired and disbanded
and here's the list of names of people
who came to my house and nobody can do
it better but they're under siege
they don't want to lose their house they
don't want to lose their families
what they do to police officers
what they do to police and you're always
going to have some bad apples but
they're very few
and we have a country that's become
one of the most unsafe countries in the
world think of it you know we're dealing
with third world nations where they're
much safer than
major parts think of it what i said in
afghanistan we didn't lose one soldier
in 18 months and yet i just read off
numbers in philadelphia if you look at
atlanta
i have a district attorney in atlanta
she's after me for a perfect phone call
and yet it's even worse proportionately
than chicago for killing but the
district attorney trump made a phone
call because he was challenging
the election
so they're after me for a perfect by the
way perfect phone call you'd be very
proud of me totally just like the call
to ukraine was a perfect call the one in
atlanta was a perfect call the crowd
seems really bored atlanta is even worse
than chicago
proportionately restoring safety to
america starts with defeating the
democratic streamers right here in
pennsylvania your state's radical
democrat candidate for senate
john fetterman is the most dangerous
democrat
he's the most suddenly he's worse than
aoc all of a sudden
seeking to join congress this year in
one of the most fringe far-left freak
shows ever to seek election
for any office in any state you know
i've watched him over the last couple of
years and i said you got to be kidding
actually i thought conor lamb i don't
know conor lamb but i thought he was
maybe a decent politician
you know he he campaigned in a sort of a
middle democrat area and he was doing
commercials that was so good for me that
people thought that he was a republican
i like connor lamp
but fetterman got it and he got it in a
landslide and this he likes that lamb
better than us but soon i've never seen
him wear a suit a dirty dirty dirty
sweatsuit it's really disgusting you
know i'm a clean freak
i'm a clean freak oz i don't like those
dirty sweatsuits they're disgusting
[Applause]
fetterman may dress like a teenager
getting high in his
parents basement
but he's a raging lunatic helmet or
springing hardened criminals out of jail
it's the lieutenant governor of
pennsylvania he's talking about by the
way in pennsylvania history he wants
everybody out of jail and by the way he
wants to get rid of your police
fetterman is a defunder the police
marxist
who's just pulling the wool over
people's eyes who literally said that if
he had a magic wand
and could fix one thing he would end
life sentences without parole from
murderers cop killers rapists and other
monsters
you realize all that means is they would
be subject to parole like it doesn't
actually mean they get paroled yeah
let's put trump in jail let's get these
murderers let these murderers out put
trump in jail that trump is no damn good
he just works his ass off for this
country
through his position on the pennsylvania
board of pardons
fetterman has released a record number
of dangerous criminals back onto the
streets
many of which have created horrible just
atrocious crimes he supports setting
loose one out of every three inmates
in your prisons and he bragged that his
goal is to get as many criminals out
onto the street
as quickly as possible
fetterman supports taxpayer-funded drug
dens
and the complete decriminalization of
illegal drugs a good time though
including
heroin
cocaine
crystal meth
and ultra lethal fentanyl and by the way
he takes them himself
which would mean death
and despair for every
fetterman's on on fentanyl community in
the united states of america
compare that to president xi of china a
little different would you say
fetterman openly supports deadly
sanctuary cities
and he signed a pledge to ban fracking
which would demolish
almost a million jobs
in pennsylvania i told him i told you
they were going to do that pennsylvania
well you did listen to me because i won
pennsylvania by a lot
the noise causes i can't i can't hold
i can only hold
accountable the stupid people that
counted the votes did you ever hear
the statement by i believe it was lenin
did anyone ever hear of any mean
people would say it with less
sophistication lenin
lenin i like the way they say that
where he said
the vote counter
is far more important than the candidate
well that turned out to be true the vote
counter is far more important than the
candidate said by
lenin
and while fetterman wants to raise your
taxes
he is a spoiled and entitled
socialist loser who leeched off his
parents money you know he lives on the
paris money until he was 49 years old
and on top of it all
he's too cowardly isn't trump's entire
business and political career thanks to
him leeching off of his dad he's very
nice
oz you'll treat him nicely right
[Applause]
because he knows that his positions are
totally indefensible and in all fairness
you need somebody that's going to be out
there and just ripping it for you
otherwise you're going to lose out to
all the other senators that are going to
bring back money to their states etc and
oz will do it fetterman is running
against a man i have known for many
years i told you i had a real problem
with him when he said i was a little
heavy i didn't like that
and of course it was false right was he
wrong
and who is with our
maga movement all the way he's with us
all the way
and you know some people thought that oh
gee maybe this was a little bit of a
controversial thing but i know him very
well
and he's a guy that gets it done he's a
good person too his wife is
a fantastic person i think i like her
even more than i like him lisa
yeah so lisa oz i'd like to ask dr oz to
step forward
and
say a few oh this should be special huh
successful man on television and
medicine he knows what's he's going to
drink silver solution on stage for us
for pennsylvania thank you
pennsylvania we have one question
one important question we have to answer
by november 8th are you ready for it
is the country headed
in the right direction
yeah
find me a metric that says otherwise
take away their car keys they should not
be driving
in that condition people should stay
home
but if the answer is no we've got a big
problem this country has dramatically
turned in the wrong direction
i'm the person for change
i'll make the change based on our family
values here in pennsylvania because i
believe trump's bored because oz you're
supposed to talk about trump when he
calls you up and oz isn't doing it work
and earning and supporting other
americans because that's what americans
do i believe we can make safe city
streets in communities i believe we can
have a secure border and allow legal
immigration but not the fentanyl brought
by traffickers bringing human beings and
fentanyl from china we took a hundred
thousand lives last year and i know
people in this audience have been hurt
by fentanyl i believe we could have an
economy that helps the american people
but most importantly
i believe in each and every one of you
and so should you god bless you this is
really sad
so we have a great record of endorsement
all of us together it's about to get
worse it's very close to 99 and i
endorse that guy and i'm telling you
i will
always tell you this i'll tell you the
truth and he is going to be a phenomenal
representative for pennsylvania you got
to vote him in he's going to lose he's
got a vote
a great guy
that guy
vote for that guy and lisa thank you
very much thank you very much
what you have to put up with lisa that's
the best thank you very much you know
they spent just so you know
they spent like 50 million dollars
trying to destroy that man 50 million
dollars like it was water
and they didn't come close this guy is
tough and he's strong and he loves this
state
this november you also have to defeat
the far left democrat candidate for
governor
little josh shapiro shapiro is a total
center-left democrat completely
uncontroversial in every way that he's
about half his height which is fine
just fine i always say it's absolutely
fine because we don't want to tell
height jokes you can't tell any jokes
today
not weight jokes not hate jokes i've got
them all covered
but
he is a disaster for the state
he's the one that kept saying oh
after
after it came out that we have a great
man running against him oh that's the
man i wanted to run against no it's not
because that's the man that had a base
like i do he has a base that's so
powerful and so strong
he doesn't want to run again
as attorney general he presided over
the complete disintegration of law and
order and letting gangs and criminals
run wild look at the numbers i just
talked to you about in philadelphia well
he's the guy
and those numbers are getting worse
there's nothing to stop these animals
from continuing those numbers are going
to get worse if that's possible it's not
even you would think it's not possible
shapiro
supports sanctuary cities he sided with
marxist anti-american blm radicals and
antifa
and he's a vicious hater of free speech
and
a hater of your second amendment so he's
gonna let criminals roam your streets
and he's not gonna let you have a gun to
protect yourself there you go shapiro is
also using his office to shut down your
children's schools
and force masks to be strapped to your
children's faces wait they're shutting
down schools in pennsylvania now i did
not hear that
and like fatterman shapiro is a
pro-abortion extremist who supports
totally unrestricted abortion on demand
right through the ninth month
think of this
and you know where i am
you know where i am the exceptions i
believe in the exceptions he supports it
though right through
the ninth month and beyond you know what
beyond means it's a lie
the baby is born that's a lie
the baby is born
so as i said in my debate with
crooked hillary clinton
rip the baby out of the womb at any time
and if the baby's already out of the
womb
he's there too
just talk to the doctor
no you don't want that the states will
make the decision by the way
the states will make the decision
and in pennsylvania
i have a feeling that decision will
be an interesting decision but it's up
to the states and that's where it was
always supposed to be but he wants to
let things happen that no
civilized person
would allow they don't allow it in other
countries
no pennsylvanians should listen to one
word an abortion from
these two twisted sickos who believe in
killing and dismembering babies right up
until that
that time that time of birth shapiro is
so dumb incredible patriot and a
fearless warrior for pennsylvania
workers
and pennsylvania values doug mastriano
who has been with me right
from the beginning i mean right from the
beginning
i remember that they all wanted my
endorsement they all ran i know you had
the u.s attorney nice guy he was a nice
guy but he did nothing in terms of the
election fraud no there was no problem
in pennsylvania there was no problem in
philadelphia there was massive problems
and then he wants to run he said sir
bill barr would not let me go after
anybody he wouldn't let me touch anybody
what a shame what an opportunity but he
wanted to run others wanted to run and
trump was like when you're famous you
just touch whoever you want that
supported election integrity and
supported me right from the beginning
is
doug mastriano
the one guy
he came to the white house
came to the white house with a whole
group of people he brought him and he
was fighting like hell it was a really
an uphill battle because you had the
democrats they didn't want to hear
anything and then you had some
bad rhinos that just uh
somebody someday somebody's going to
explain to rhinos why are they doing it
but doug is a former army colonel who
honorably served our country in uniform
for 30 years
before going on to fight for you
in the state senate became the most
respected person in the senate and
definitely the hardest fighter
he was a relentless
person
out there fighting against lockdowns and
coveted mandates he didn't want to
destroy our children he got it long
before the so-called doctors who weren't
very good and a true champion for
election integrity and tough as hell on
a thing called illegal immigration he
wants people to come into our country
legally as your governor
he will back down everybody he'll back
down those violent criminals and they'll
crack down on violent crime and covet
mandates
protect pennsylvania oil and gas what
coveted mandates are there anyway enjoy
your job for another couple of months
because you're not going to have it
longer
and defend your jobs your rights and
your freedoms
doug is joined
by an incredible person who i also got
to know because we were in a real fight
with a lot of really sick
bad
people twisted rebbe thank you very much
thank you stand up
and she was a big part
she's a great partner to a man that will
become one of the greatest governors
in this country
doug please come up please come up
the reason trump loves masteriano is
masteriano's made it clear
if a democrat wins pennsylvania in 2024
he'll try to give the election of the
into the republican
thank you mr president
pennsylvania loves you and america needs
you thank you for your leadership
thank you for paving the way for people
like me and everyone you see out here to
fight for freedom thank you for taking
his shots and standing boldly and
leading by example
pennsylvania
pennsylvania is a keystone state on 8
november we're taking our state back by
storm
he's going to leave
we're going to do it he's going to leave
it
we're going to be the state where people
want to come to raise their families and
to succeed in business on day one we're
out of the regional greenhouse gas
initiative we're gonna drill and dig
like no tomorrow oh god get him out of
here
i i hope this guy loses
we're gonna do it
oh yeah on day one we're no longer a
sanctuary state so joe biden had these
illegal we'll dump him off at his beach
house where he spends all his time
anyway
on day one we're gonna have the backs of
our beautiful law enforcement on day one
there's no more mass requirement or
covet jab requirement
that's right
we're gonna walk like free people like
never before
pennsylvania they're all enslaved right
now they'll be free soon flight of
liberty was lit in 1776 a new birth of
freedom in 1863
and something very near and dear to both
of our hearts we're gonna fight like
hell for voting integrity and we're
gonna start with voter id that's code
for i will steal the election for you
sir in case you uh lose pennsylvania in
2024
the left
[Applause]
my opponent is too dangerous too extreme
and too radical for pennsylvania he
can't even define what a woman is i mean
the guy is nuts
pennsylvania is less safe with his
six-year record of failure as attorney
general that all ends on eight november
right
pennsylvania's screwed if this guy wins
the key to our nation starts with us
and let's not forget on in 2001 and you
were a champion of 9 11 2001 yeah he
bragged that his building was now the
tallest column
at the world trade center meanwhile
flight 93 over somerset county the
terrorists had it
todd beamer and other people on that
plate took action what did they say
pennsylvania let's roll thank you
let's really hope he's defeated in
november
you know doug said a lot
in a few
short sentences one of the things he
mentioned was voter id
now
the democrats
don't want voter id
actually it's interesting the leadership
the people
want it 91 democrats but the leaders
don't want voter id okay so think the
only reason you don't want voter id
there's only one way because you want to
cheat right that's the only reason
when you had the democrat national
convention
so it's looking like the people that
took the over on trump going 90 minutes
are about to win trump's been speaking
an hour and 24 minutes we are six
minutes from him hitting the 90-minute
mark over the last few days starbucks
remember schultz this guy schultz
the one with the extremely thin legs i
think maybe dr oz would have said he's
either really good or very very very
thin but he was doing a debate he was
sitting down i thought his legs i didn't
think he'd be able to stand up
but schulz he's the head of it
and he just announced
unions are trying to take over starbucks
but he will not under any circumstance
allow mail-in voting because it's
evil
and corrupt
and the process can be corrupted and yet
when he was running for president for
about three days before he realized he
couldn't win took him about uh two days
lady in the blue bailing is that what's
going on people are coming in where did
these guys just come from are people
rotated up onto the stage this company
that he's got a nice piece of he wants
nothing to do with voting by mail-in
ballots for unions
because he says you can't get
a fair vote and it's easily corruptable
when are people going to get smart get
rid of this mail in voting it's killing
our country
all right you'll do it
we're also joined tonight by the next
congressman from pennsylvania's eighth
congressional district
jim
bognett jim thank you very much
thank you jim
good luck i hear you're doing well jim
well these two guys are going to help
you a lot thank you jim great job
so jim's running against
radical democrat socialist matt
cartwright that's another beauty
[Applause]
who said he's all abroad
he is all on board
for the green new deal greatest waste of
money in history
the green new deal why don't you just
throw the money right out the window
and he absolutely supports defunding the
police
and votes with biden
100 of the time so you know he can't be
any good
everybody get out and vote for jim
okay
right jim bognett
also with us our pennsylvania treasurer
a very good person good woman
stacy garrity stacy thank you
where's stacy
hello stacy
thank you stacy great job you're doing
a friend of mine a warrior
never let me down always been there
representative
dan muser
dan thank you
great job
great job thank you dan
[Applause]
and also fred keller another warrior
fred stand up fred what a good guy
really naming everybody oh
he comes state senator jack mayerhoffer
is here as well big supporter now a
woman is with us who's very silent very
shy
doesn't believe in using guns to protect
yourself
says anybody can come into my house
anytime you'd like
no no she did a little ad i saw her
first time
and her ad was something to the effect
sure
anybody
can come into my house
ding ding ding and then she took this
gun i never saw anybody use a gun
boom put it back and she said
but he might not get out of my house
alive
and i said i think i like her
marjorie taylor greene
a man i'm very proud of
he's got a tough race
but i'm very proud of him uh because you
have a rhino
governor
in maryland his name is larry hogan i
think he wants to run for president
i think he wants to run for president i
said you got to look in the mirror first
it's not going to work not going to work
but he's a real rhino
and he doesn't want this man because
this man is
all for our country
his name is dan cox and he beat
he beat larry hogan's candidate by like
20 points
with my endorsement
with my endorsement and he's doing
fantastically dan congratulations
and larry hogan
and this is my fault i'm sorry dan but
larry hogan is uh not going to be
supporting you only because i am
supporting you right so i don't know
what that means but i can tell you that
maryland has a great
a great man running and i hope you're
going to do well and we'll be out there
helping you okay thank you very much
i have a feeling you do very well
a friend of mine who's a great
businessman and a great person
mr woody johnson and his wife suzanne
johnson where is woody stand up woody
he's shy
they own a very small company named
johnson and johnson does anybody like
johnson
i want to own a piece of that company
too
great job
we love you both
and cynthia hughes and gina perno with
the patriot freedom project what a job
they do where are you
where are you stand up what a job and we
all appreciate it we all appreciate it
with the help of everybody here today we
are going to fight for pennsylvania
we're going to win for pennsylvania this
november one of the first things we will
do is stand up for parents right you
really can't write this crap right
trump's trump's enthralled with cox and
johnson's i mean it's you it's it's
beyond parody years ago let's put
yourself back that somebody would stand
up i can't believe i'm calling myself a
politician but i guess i am i don't know
i can't stand politicians
but can you believe that 10 years ago
like put yourself in that position
a politician would be standing up saying
we're going to defend parental rights i
mean is that about as basic as it gets
but that's what we have to do because
these people are crazy
our children are captive to unhinged
marxist
educators who are pushing inappropriate
sexual racial and political material on
our children
from the youngest possible age
at long last every parent in america
must be empowered to opt out
of the indoctrination and send their
child to the public private charter
religious or home school charter of
their choice
in addition we will get critical race
theory the hell out of it is he gonna do
the teach transgender line guys real
quick in the chat is he gonna do the
teach transgender and local governments
just like i did two years ago it was out
we had it out but they put it right back
in
we will also keep men out of women's
sports
you know those stories that i tell i
love to tell those stories the woman
swimmer should i tell it again
you want me to
the mr wall stand up wall please this is
mr irving q wall look
people love trump's transphobic stories
and you know it's not politically
correct and a lot of people are afraid
to talk about it but i'm not
men in women's sports so you have the
swimmer who's a really i met her
the other day very
high quality swimmer and she's gonna
break the record she's worked like hell
she's worked all her life the big beat
is on and
she looks to the left and she sees all
of those great athletes that she's been
fighting for years she looks to the
right and she sees but next to us this
massive human being
she's looking up isn't he like six six
or something he's got a wingspan bigger
than wilt chamberlain
wilt was small by comparison
and she looked over i've never seen her
before
anyway
this is really bad because she fought so
hard to do it
and the race started and as you know she
was severely injured she was injured by
wind burn because he went by her so fast
the wind burned the hell out of her
and she didn't quite make it that day
for the record but he did he broke the
record by 38 seconds you know usually
you break it by she wanted to break it
by one-eighth of a second but he was far
better than her he broke it by 38
seconds that's one that no woman's ever
gonna catch i don't think republican
humor folks there you had a woman she's
gonna lift the 213 pounds and she's
gonna that's a lot of weight
do you think i could lift us do you
think i could lift 213.
and she got up and she was gonna break
it they put it half an ounce and a half
an ounce they had these big barbells and
dumbbells and she's up there and she
pulls it up and she's gonna do it
ah
i couldn't do it she's sorry she was
ashamed but she couldn't
and then this person
comes in you know they actually called
this a correct term
a person in a man's body that's what
they call it this is supposed to be
politically correct i hope it is
otherwise they'll be very rude to me
the fake news will be very rude
[Applause]
so this guy walks up
they asked him before did you lift
before no not too much
and he gets up
being
that was the end of that record
it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous and no teachers should
ever be allowed to teach transgender to
our children without and there it is
and there it is
everybody who took the yes he will say
it on that one
you win it's it's sort of a pyrrhic
victory we all lose actually but for
free speech in america which we don't
have we don't have free speech
go out and sign up now by the way for
truth social anybody on truth social
truth essential
truth essential and it's much better
than twitter
it's not hot it's been banned from the
google play store they owe 1.6 million
to their web host and are probably going
bankrupt soon radical left democrat
party
is not in my opinion a 50 party within
our country
they're against god guns oil law
enforcement voter id tax cuts regulation
cuts
the constitution and they're against our
founding fathers other than that
actually they're quite good
the way they win is to cheat in
elections i really believe that how can
you be against
all of those things and for some of the
things that they're for
and be considered a 50 50 party i don't
believe it they cheat like hell on
elections all over the country and
they're really good at it everywhere the
republican party has the chance we must
pass
critical election integrity reforms
including universal voter id citizenship
confirmation
no more fake drop boxes by zuckerberg
and these people so for people wondering
he's been speaking an hour and 39
minutes now it is starting to be
reminiscent to fidel castro
uh i am taking the under on two hours i
don't think he will go two hours
same day paper
france just had an election big country
35 million people
say same-day voting
yeah so smaller than california election
ended at 11 o'clock they had the vote
that was it nobody walked away
complaining
right here in pennsylvania oh actually
france's population is 67 million maybe
he means only 35 million voted 97
clearly violates your state constitution
encouraging widespread abuse of mail-in
ballots
and your radical left state supreme
court just violated the constitution a
second time by overturning a decision by
an unbiased
lower court republicans in the state
legislature need to get to work
immediately to kill acts 77 by a state
constitutional amendment they have to do
it immediately
we are just this is so riveting and
electric i hope he goes two more hours
in american history
and we need a landslide so big that the
radical left just cannot rig it you know
the more we win by it gets harder harder
harder harder
they can cheat a lot but once you get to
a certain level it gets very hard this
is the year
we're going to take back the house we're
going to take back the senate we're
going to take back america
and take back america
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back our
magnificent white house
together we will fight for more jobs for
pennsylvania families fair trade for
pennsylvania workers
and more pennsylvania factories forging
more products stamped with those
beautiful beautiful words
made in the usa right
made in the usa
we will shut down biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in mexico policy how good was that
remain in mexico do you think it was
easy for me to get remain in mexico from
mexico but i got it
i said you don't give it to me you're
gonna pay big tariffs on your cars oh
we'd love to give it to you
strengthen the patriots of ice and
border patrol they're patriots and
they're great we will again end catch
and release
we will end chain migration we will end
the visa lottery and we will clamp down
on illegal immigration just like we did
less than two years ago when we had
the safest border in our country's
history
we will stop the crime wave in
democrat-run cities we will give our
police the power they need and the
respect
they deserve
and we will not take legal protection i
have to say amish for trump is not a
sign i've seen before maniacs want to
have the police officers go out and hire
lawyers
so they can defend themselves we won't
do that
we will restore law and order in america
and we will override governors that
don't look for law and order
we will hold china accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world we
will protect innocent life we will
defend our constitution we will defend
the second amendment and we will proudly
uphold the judeo-christian values and
principles
he means just christian not
judeo-christian
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our great
american flag
in conclusion
our maga movement make america great
again
is by far the greatest political
movement in the history of our country
together we are standing up against some
of the most menacing forces
entrenched interests and vicious
opponents our people
have ever seen
despite great outside dangers our
biggest threat remains the sick
sinister and evil people
from within our own country
but no matter how big or powerful the
corrupt radical left democrats are and
they are corrupt and they are powerful
we have to make them much less powerful
we will never
allow anyone to forget
that this nation does not belong to them
this nation
belongs to you
this is your home this is your heritage
and our american liberty is your
god-given right
from allentown to johnstown from
harrisburg to pittsburgh
and from philadelphia to scranton pa
we stand on the shoulders of american
legends who poured out their blood sweat
and tears for our rights and for our
freedom
they were so great
pennsylvania is where our founding
fathers declared
american independence it's where the
army weathered its brutal winter at
valley forge
where general george washington led his
men on a daring mission across the
delaware
[Music]
and where our union was saved by
immortal heroes at gettysburg
and this is the state where generations
of tough strong pennsylvania miners
factory workers and steel workers forged
the greatest nation in the history
of the world
but now we are a nation
in decline
we are a nation
that is failing
we are a nation
that has the highest inflation in over
50 years
and where the stock market just finished
the worst first half of the year
since 1800
notice he won't talk about july which is
in the second half of the year or august
history
we are no longer
energy independent or energy dominant
as we just
were
two short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
venezuela saudi arabia
and many others for oil please please
please help us
joe biden says
yet we have more liquid gold right under
our feet
than any other country in the world
we are a nation that is consumed by the
radical f's green new deal
yet everyone knows that the green new
deal will lead to our destruction
we are a nation that is
surrendering
all over
but in particular what's that noise
anybody know what that noise is dead
soldiers
american citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest
military equipment anywhere in the world
we are a nation that allowed russia to
devastate a country ukraine
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse
it would never have happened with me as
your commander-in-chief
and for four long years it didn't the
speech is indoors guys for people hoping
trump gets hit by lightning the speech
is indoors china
with taiwan
is next
we are a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party
like never before
we've got a federal bureau of
investigation that won't allow bad
election changing facts is there a song
playing now
to the public
and a department of justice that refuses
to investigate egregious acts of voting
irregularities and fraud and we have a
president who is
cognitively impaired
and in no condition to lead our country
and everybody knows it
[Music]
are they playing them off we are did
trump go too long as a free and fair
press
fake news is all you get
and they are truly
the enemy
of the people
we are a nation where they might have
only paid for the venue till 9 30.
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been collapsing
where more people died of covet in 2021
than did in 2020.
we are a nation that is allowing iran to
build a massive nuclear is this
genuinely a propaganda soundtrack
probably being allowed to do right now
in china
to use trillions and trillions of
dollars that is taken from us
to build a military to rival our own
and just two years ago we had iran china
russia
and north korea in check
they weren't going to do a thing against
us
and everybody knows it
and perhaps most importantly we are a
nation that is no longer respected
or listened to around this is cringier
than any of the rallies i've covered
that he's done anyways
has become a joke
we are a nation that is
hostile to liberty
freedom and faith
we are a nation whose economy is
floundering
whose stores are not stocked he's
completely lost the crowd coming
and whose educational system is ranked
at the bottom of every single list
but we are not going to let this
continue
two years ago we had the greatest
election
that we've had sorry
but it was taken away from us
we weren't allowed
to use the power of the people
to make america
great again
two years
ago we also had greatness like no one
had ever seen oh my god and soon we will
have
that greatness again
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you
who are going to save our country
we will stand up to the radical left
lunatics and the rhinos and we will
fight for america
like no one has ever fought before
okay
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is no victory we cannot have
we will not bend we will not break we
will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up
we will never ever ever back down
as long as we are confident in united
the tyrants we are fighting
do not
stand even a chance
because we are americans and americans
deal to god and god alone
[Music]
my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we are on together
has only just been this is a very bad
attempt
at overtly fascistic speech types we are
one movement
one people
one family and one glorious american
nation
so with the help of everyone here today
as citizens all across our land
we will make america powerful again
we will make
america wealthy again
we will make
america strong again
we will make america
proud again
we will make
america safe again the song's back
and we
will make america
great again
thank you very much god bless you all
thank you pennsylvania thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
well there it is
very dark
[Music]
[Applause]
folks clocking in at one hour
and 54 minutes
trump is finally done
finally done
truly bizarre
look at this guy
man
it did feel longer than lord of the
rings and i hate lord of the rings i
just can't take it and lord of the rings
feels very long to me this felt even
longer
oz must be long gone back to jersey
right i mean it just it can't possibly
still be there
all right everybody listen that was
extraordinarily dystopian
extraordinarily dystopian um listen
make sure that you subscribe on youtube
and follow on twitch so that when we
start covering all of the different
debates if warnock and walker ever
debate i'll be covering it uh there are
a bunch of debates coming i don't want
you to miss them we'll be live for all
of the stuff as donald trump
uh kind of confusedly lumbers back into
the tunnel and goes uh
yeah he should go you should go it's
over all right everybody we'll see you
very soon thank you for joining me and i
do apologize to everybody that found it
disgusting and it was very very
disgusting all right everybody we will
see you
very very soon
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
ducks
dumps